[Musique]
Messieurs, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Serview. Nous sommes en
direct.
Bonjour.
Bernardoyer. Est-ce que vous voulez bien
vous présenter succintement ?
Bah, je suis un autorinologiste qui a
longtemps exercé avec passion son métier
et qui suis rentré tardivement dans la
vie publique, la vie politique. Et j'ai
été élu successivement maire,
conseiller départemental et député.
Il faut vous appeler docteur ou colonel
?
Appelez-moi Bernard.
Henry Progliot, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Ouais.
Alors moi je suis euh méditerranéen
d'origine. J'ai bah passé toute ma vie
dans l'entreprise la générale des eau
devenue et violia d'une part et puis
d'autre part dont j'ai présidé aux
destinées pendant
10 15 ans pour l'une et 5 ans pour
l'autre.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler industrie
nucléaire, énergie, finances,
prospective et qu'est-ce qui nous reste
pour la France ? Je vais essayer de vous
mettre un peu sous pression. Ça va être
compliqué parce que vous êtes vous avez
un peu de bouteille tous les deux.
Qu'est-ce que vous pourriez dire à un
jeune français pour pas qu'il quitte le
pays ? Bernard
que la France est un pays magnifique,
qui est un pays qui a des atouts
formidables
mais qui depuis un certain nombre
d'années
ne les exploite plus, les néglige et
s'est endormi. S'est endormi parce que
il doute, il se laisse aller et si on a
la volonté, si on a un peu d'ambition et
bien la France retrouvera la place
qu'elle a eu jadisme et qu'elle est en
train de perdre à une vitesse
malheureusement assez grande. Henry
avant de donner la parole, on va
challenger le tbib. Elle s'est endormie
parce queon l'a sédé ou elle s'est
endormie parce qu'elle s'est endormie
sur ses lauriers ?
Elle s'est endormie parce qu'elle refuse
le réel parce que depuis la caricature
est facile mais c'est depuis mai 68 et
les slogans que l'on connaît qui étaient
des slogans qui niaient les réalités qui
refusaient refusaient les réalités de la
vie. euh il est interdit d'interdire euh
jouir sans entrave et cetera et cetera
et bien on a continué sur la même ligne
et aujourd'hui ben on refuse de regarder
la dette, on refuse de regarder l'état
du monde, les menaces géopolitiques qui
planent et on se laisse aller.
On reviendra sur la sédation. Henri,
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire à un jeune
français pour qu'il reste dans le pays ?
On n'est pas peut-être pas obligé de lui
conseiller de rester dans le pays
d'ailleurs.
Bah la question se pose enfin quand on
est patriote, on a quand même envie de
de sauver la France. Euh
et ça ça nous réunit au fond.
Je pense que ce pays manque de de de
leadership. Enfin, je sais pas comment
l'exprimer en français. Si on a quand on
avait des des
responsables qu'il soient chef
d'entreprise, qu'il soient homme
politique et cetera, qui montrait la
voix, qui montrait le chemin, qui
montrait qu'il y avait une ambition, une
volonté ex
de Gaulle,
de Gaulle, Pompidou, même Giscar, même
enfin bien sûr Chac pour qui j'ai une
affection particulière, mais ils ont ils
ont au fond enthousiasmé
[Musique]
ils ont ils ont guidé ce pays.
Et puis il y a eu des grands chefs
d'entreprise aussi de la même manière.
Enfin, on avait des classes dirigeantes
qui étaient euh remarquables, qui ont
qui ont créé qui ont bâti la France tel
qu'on l'a connu. Et puis je sais pas
pourquoi cette dégénérescence s'est
produite. Euh et aujourd'hui,
je
envie de dire aux jeunes, bah soyez
soyez
vous-même les leaders dont nous avons
besoin parce queon peut pas leur donner
beaucoup d'exemples de de réussite et de
de enfin de au fond de de d'exemplarité
dans le monde actuel.
Bernard, est-ce que vous souhaitez
rebondir ou est-ce que on creuse la
sédation française ?
Non, je pense que il y aura il y aura un
rebond, c'est nécessaire. Ce qui est
inquiétant, c'est là où l'on doute,
c'est
qu'est-ce qui va créer ce rebond ? Et
comme comme le dit euh Henri Progliot,
quel sera le chef charismatique qui
saura convaincre le pays pour que le
pays se réveille, pour qu'il est un
projet, qu'il adhère au projet que ce
leader portera ? Et bien sûr, comme
toujours, la France se rebondira. Celle
de notre histoire multiséculaire, il y a
toujours eu quelqu'un qui est arrivé. On
reconnaît l'optimisme du boomer.
C'est le rebond du chat mort. Les
perspectives sont les suivantes. La
Chine construit une dizaine de réacteurs
nucléaires à l'heure actuelle.
Comment ?
Par an.
Par an. Merci. La Chine a déjà des
capacités énergétiques trois fois
supérieures à l'Europe. On vient de se
couper avec les Russes. On a plus
d'énergie pour marcher. On a plus
d'intrés
énergétiques, soit vieillissantes, soit
sous pression de l'extérieur comme
l'Allemagne qui a essayé de nous faire
des des crocheppatttes à longueur de
journée comme les Russes qui ont financé
les verts allemands aussi pour nous
faire des crocheppatttes. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait là ? On prend notre leader
charismatique et lumineux Emmanuel
Macron et toute sa toute sa petite
équipe. On fait quoi là ?
Depuis 5 ans, j'ai décidé et j'ai été
convaincu par un ami qui a été au
commissaire à l'énergie atomique de
Brchet
Yve Brchet que je devais me consacrer à
mettre en œuvre les relations que j'ai
pu nouer, les connaissances que j'ai pu
équérir qui conduisent à la décision
parce que la décision est toujours
politique afin que ces gens-là, ceux-là
ouvrent les yeux sur les réalités du
problème énergétique, sur les graves
erreurs qui ont été commises depuis plus
de 10 ans,
il faut les détailler
et et qui conduisent à la situation
d'aujourd'hui. Ces erreurs, on y
reviendra certainement. C'est d'abord
une énorme erreur qui consiste sur un
accord électoral politique en 2012 au
moment de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012.
Cet accord entre Europe écologie les
verts et
le Parti socialiste dont le candidat est
François Hollande pour la présidentielle
de 2012. cet accord qui n'a aucun
fondement physique, aucun fondement
sur la moindre étude consiste à à dire
on va fermer
euh 14 réacteurs d'ici nucléaires d'ici
2025 et réduire la part du nucléaire
dans le mix électrique français.
C'est c'est une faute inqualifiable.
C'est une trahison et on voit encore
pérorer ceux qui ont conduit cette
sinistre initiative sur les plateaux de
télévision, voir
euh manifester des ambitions pour peser
encore dans la vie. Tout ça a été brisé
par un minable accord politique, celui
de 2012.
Henri, est-ce qu'on rebondit là-dessus
ou
Ouais, on peut rebondir. Enfin, moi j'ai
j'ai
dans le cadre de commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur
euh sur souveraineté énergétique
détaillé ce ce sujet
au fond. Euh effectivement euh après une
première entorse qui avait eu lieu du
temps de la cohabitation Jospin
et et et voiné qui avait arrêté les
recteurs de rapide enfin qui était la
première fois dans l'histoire de la 5e
République que le pouvoir en place
revenait sur je dirais cette cette
conviction au fond que le nucléaire
faisait partie des grands atouts de la
France. Euh bon donc premier entorse à
ce moment-là, c'est le bon
et puis surtout effectivement 2012 et
l'accord vert et rose qui s'est qui est
conduit à cette énorme
aberration qui était le refus du
nucléaire en tout cas
la décision de réduire la part du
nucléaire
à combien ? 50 %.
La question qui m'a été posée c'était
d'où sort ce chiffre parfaitement au
doigt mouillé. Bon parce qu'
ces gens-là ne savaient même pas de quoi
il parlait. On leur a dit que le
nucléaire représentait 75 % de la
production électrique française. Donc
ils ont dit bon ben on va faire 50.
C'est tout. C'est pas il y a aucun
calcul, aucune réflexion, aucune
stratégie sous-jacente.
ça continuant seulement à
au fond
un programme absurde qui effectivement
amenait la fermeture de la moitié de nos
réacteurs nucléaires mais bon qui a été
immédiatement corrigé par le candidat
qui a vu que l'accord était complètement
irréaliste et qui donc s'est retranché
dans une espèce de position ambigue.
Bon faut réduire la part nucléaire mais
je m'engage à fermer Fim. Pourquoi Fim ?
Parce qu'au dernier moment, on lui a dit
bah quelle est la plus ancienne ? C'est
Fahim. OK, bon on va fermer la plus
ancienne. Personne ne savait qu'elle
venait d'être rénovée complètement. Ce
que j'ai dit d'ailleurs la commission
d'enquête qu'on avait investi 2
milliards et demi d'euros pour la
rénovation et la modernisation totale de
cette unité. enfin
d'ent mais mais c'est surtout des
conséquences indirecte que cela implique
parce qu'au fond ça revenir à dire le
nucléaire n'a pas d'avenir
et ça a été d'ailleurs assez clairement
annoncé et donc la machine à recruter
les talents c'est enrayé quand on dit à
des gens qui vont pas être payés de
manière très
très spectaculaire parce qu'au fond EDF
payer pay un peu moins bien que
l'industrie qui payait beaucoup moins
bien que la finance et donc les
ingénieurs sont des grandes écoles
avait par fierté
rejoint je dirais l'aventure nucléaire
dès le jour où on leur dit que leur
fierté est mal placée qu'au fond ils
n'ont pas d'avenir qu' font qui se se
consacre à un métier qui qui est qui
n'est pas respectable qu'en plus ils
sont mal payés bon évidemment
la machine à recruter les talents, c'est
enrayé. Donc perd de savoir
et ça fait 15 ans bien sûr que non
seulement on a sous-investi
mais qu'en plus on a abîmé le capital de
science et et de compétences dont
disposait la France donc DF en
l'occurrence parce que bah au fond on ne
recrutait plus les meilleurs dans la
fère nucléaire et aujourd'hui on a beau
dire on va relancer le nucléaire on
lance avec quoi et avec qui avec quel
argent puisque que
peut-être savez-vous qu'on a des
problèmes budgétaires ? Peut-être, ça
c'est rien. Va parler des problèmes
budgétaires, on va se marer aussi hein.
Mais mais avec qui ?
Bernard, euh vous avez été euh
le grand patron de l'Assemblée
nationale, c'est ça ?
Oui, j'ai j'ai présidé le l'Assemblée
nationale de 2007 à 2008.
Donc, vous avez une petite expérience du
niveau des députés.
B
sur ce sujet,
on ne peut que déplorer le recul de la
prise en compte de la science dans les
décisions publiques. C'est un sujet qui
m'a passionné quand j'étais élu, qui
continue de me passionner aujourd'hui
depuis que j'essaie de convaincre
évidemment totalement bénévolement
les élus,
l'exécutif
de la fausse route que Henriot vient de
de détailler avec des conséquences
extrêmement lourdes. Je suis d'une
nature optimiste, donc je pense que on y
arrivera. Ça va être très difficile et
quand c'est difficile et bien il faut de
la volonté politique. Donc une fois de
plus, tout est politique. C'est
d'ailleurs ce qui m'avait conduit à
rentrer dans la vie publique. Et là
encore plus que pour les autres sujets.
Soit la France et ceux qui vont la
diriger comprennent que le nucléaire
c'est la dernière filière industrielle
qui peut permettre d'espérer une
réindustrialisation
et donc il faut y mettre les moyens pour
relancer cette filière. Soit ça passe au
second plan et là ce sera très
inquiétant. Mais comme je suis optimiste
et que nous faisons, nous essayons que
cela finisse par aboutir, et bien euh
nous euh espérons que ça va repartir. Et
d'ailleurs, il y a quand même euh
beaucoup de choses qui se font pour
attirer à nouveau euh de nouveaux
talents. Parfois ils sont étrangers,
mais il y a aussi quand même maintenant
des ingénieurs qui à nouveau commencent
à retrouver dans le réveil du nucléaire
au niveau mondial et dans les décisions
françaises de relancer la filière, une
voie professionnelle. Mais il y a eu un
gâchi euh humain, technique,
scientifique comme le comme vient de le
dire Henry qui est particulièrement
grave et qui condamne à mes yeux tous
ceux qui ont été les complices euh de
cette méprisable initiative politique
qui déshonore vraiment tous ceux qui s'y
sont joints.
Pour que la jeune génération comprenne
bien, si je dis si d'ici 12 mois je vois
pas des plots de béton pour des
prochaines centrales, je quitte le pays.
C'est si j'ai bien compris, c'est ça.
Je sais pas du tout dit ça. Je dis que
ça va être long. Ça sera sûrement plus
long que l'on que l'on on pourrait
l'espérer parce que les adversaires du
nucléaire ont infiltré beaucoup de
services, en particulier
des services de l'État. que la
législation et la réglementation
notamment sur la sûreté, sur
l'environnement ont été complexifiés à
dessin pour compliquer la vie, la
relance, l'avenir du nucléaire. Mais
c'est pas parce que c'est difficile
qu'il faut abandonner la bagarre. Il
faut y aller. Il faut dénoncer ce qui a
été fait et démonter un par un les
pièges qui ont été tendus.
la sédation
de puissance étrangère sur notre
potentiel nucléaire. Les Allemands qui
nous font des crochepatttes. Est-ce que
vous en tant que politique vous avez eu
une sensibilisation de qui vous
tamponne, qui nous met des croches ?
Est-ce qu'il y a eu une veille active de
nos services de renseignement pour
essayer de vous dire le cap compliqué
pour notre industrie ou pas du tout ?
Je crois qu'il faut élargir votre
question. qui
a conduit euh à cette funeste initiative
politique qui a remis en cause
l'avantage
majeur que constitue qu'a constitué et
que constitue encore le nucléaire pour
pour la France. C'est un ensemble. C'est
un ensemble constitué d'idéalistes et
d'idéologues antinucléaires par
principe,
mais également euh des
industries, des branches industrielles,
des branches énergétiques,
également l'idéologie anticapitaliste.
Pourquoi ? Parce que quand on remet en
cause la production d'énergie, quand tu
remets en cause une électricité bon
marché, fiable, décarboné, on va vers la
décroissance, on s'en prend au système
capitaliste et donc il y a un amalgame
entre des idéologues, des militants
politiques, des intérêts industriels et
commerciaux qui constituent un lobby qui
est un véritable rouleau compresseur qui
promet les qui promeut des énerg énergie
renouvelable
qui ont certes des avantages mais qui en
aucun cas ne peuvent remplacer la
production la production continue et
décarbonée et et pilotable de l'énergie
nucléaire. Et donc on a escroqué
l'opinion publique en faisant croire
qu'on pouvait remplacer des réacteurs
qui produisaient continuellement par des
installations éoliennes ou solaires qui
produisent de façon très intermittente
et très limitée.
Henry
de nouveau, je je peur de répéter. Enfin
bon, tant pis. Je crois que l'Allemagne
a joué un rôle tout à fait déterminant.
Déchaîne-toi Henri, déchaîne-toi.
Non, pas besoin de me déchaîner, je n'ai
qu'à dire ma conviction. Enfin, les
Allemands ont été les premiers sous la
pression des verts qui euh dans en
République fédérale avait une une
position politique qui a fait deux une
force assez dominante du paysage
politique allemand. en train de de de
changer considérablement en ce moment
d'ailleurs. Mais à cette époque là, il y
a une quinzaine d'années, une vingtaine
d'années, les verres ont pris position
dans les dans les
dans la démocratie allemande de manière
assez significative. C'est donc ils ont
conduit
le SPD, les socialistes, les et
l'ensemble du paysage politique allemand
à promouvoir ce qu'ils avons appelé
l'énergie 22, le tournant énergétique.
Alors, c'est vrai que l'Allemagne, avait
du retard par rapport à la France dans
ce domaine là,
avait
essentiellement
fondé son politique énergétique sur ses
ressources en charbon et en limite qui
étaient les ressources naturelles dont
disposé l'Allemagne et donc
avait très majoritairement une
production électrique à base de charbon
et de
à l'époque, en tout cas, les verts se
sont opposés à cette évolution là et
donc on conduit la l'Allemagne à
s'orienter vers d'autres sources.
Le nucléaire a fait partie de cette de
cette vis d'aventure. Si notamment s'est
lancé dans le nucléaire et et
mais n'a pas vraiment réussi là où la
France avait par contre pris euh
je dirais un virage bien avant et les
Français avaient pour une fois enfin je
dirais un avantage compétitif par
rapport à l'Allemagne dans le domaine
industriel du cœur en particulier.
Donc les Allemands euh ont constaté à la
fin
des enfin au début des années 2000
pendant la première décennie du 21e
siècle que l'énergie 22 tournait à la
catastrophe. Les deux grands
électriciens allemands se sont trouvés
au bord du dépôt de bilan sauvés par la
République fédérale.
Il était impossible, inconcevable pour
un pays
dont toute la stratégie était était
fondé autour de l'industrie et l'ost
politique qui étaient les deux grands
axes de la politique allemande
d'accepter que la France dispose de
l'atout compétitif qui donne à la France
je dirais un atout particulièrement
important en matière industrielle qui
était EDF au fond son outil électrique
et Donc
lucidement, je pense l'Allemagne a voulu
détruire DF
et donc détruire la France.
Non, détruire DF
de la France un vassal industriel et
donc pas un concurrent. Détruisant ODF
au fond, on détruisait un des atouts
compétitifs majeurs de la France en
matière industrielle.
Et donc toute la stratégie allemande a
été à travers les institutions
brusselloises
dirigé des règles qui amené à
désintégrer et à casser l'outil que la
France avait construit depuis
plus de 50 ans avec je dirais une
continuité, une pertinence, un
investissement particulier
et une efficacité extraordinaire
et une efficacité qui s'est révélée
puisque la France avait l'énergie la
moins chère d'Europe et était en plus
exportateur d'énergie électrique. Donc
fort de ce constat, toutes les règles
imaginées imposées par les Allemands
dans le cadre de l'institution
européenne avait provocation de élèves
dans ce domaineel. D'où la
désintégration du groupe, c'est-à-dire
au fond l'obligation qui a été faite à
EDF, c'est le cas aujourd'hui de ne plus
maîtriser
le transport, la distribution, c'estàd
les réseaux,
séparage
de séparer
les réseaux de l'outil de production,
c'estàd de ne plus avoir accès à ses
clients de la mise en concurrence des
barrages dont on a imaginé qu'au fond,
il fallait les mettre en appel d'offre
et donc les offrir au mieux disant.
avec les suites que ça a eu encore
récemment. Trois euh de au fond
déconsidéré le nucléaire pour pour au
fond
casser la dynamique de cette de cette
entreprise qui avait été voulue par les
autorités françaises depuis 1946 pour
être justement un atout compétitif. Les
Allemands ont réussi. Alors,
je n'ai rien à reprocher aux Allemands.
Ils ont fait ce qui était bon pour
l'Allemagne.
Et ce que j'ai dit d'ailleurs à la
représentation internationale quand j'ai
été interrogé, c'est au fond. Moi mon ma
critique va plutôt au gouvernement
français qui n'a pas défendu la France
et et ça on en retrouve des trace en
particulier depuis 2012 de manière
constante jusqu'à une date récente où
bon le gouvernement a pris l'initiative
de revenir au nucléaire en disant mais
au fond finalement relance nucléaire
relance à partir de quoi avec quoi et
donc encore une
euh une réussite d'ailleurs de la
stratégie allemande qui a été
d'affaiblir la France qui n'a pas
renforcé l'emagne mais qui a affaibli la
France.
Bernard en tant que politique et même en
tant que tout bib quand un patient est
proche du très
euh
la France le patient en France
perspective économique compliquée parce
que perspective énergétique compliqué
guerre économique compliquée concurrent
prédateur contre la France nos
politiques au milieu de tout ça on les
voit perror
s'échanger des dou mots mais la
politique industrielle est-ce que nos
élus sont conscients de tous ces dangers
et est-ce que maintenant ils ont peur de
payer l'addition de leur passivité
intellectuelle,
leur méconnaissance des fondamentaux des
sociétés thermoindustrielles ? Qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez ?
Alors, malheureusement,
on est euh
pas au fond du trou, mais on en est pas
très loin. Et comme je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure, j'ai l'intime conviction
qu'il y aura euh une inflexion, un
rebond
et qui va se manifester quand ?
Mais tout simplement,
on ressort la faucheuse
parce qu'on va mais mais tout simplement
parce qu'on va être contraint. Le la
tout ça se solde par une dette qui ne
cesse d'exploser, dont la charge
devient insupportable.
Les intérêts de la dette journalière
représentent pratiquement deux fois
notre consommation énergétique
en pétrole. Oui, à peu près. Mais euh
par jour,
il y a aussi euh le monde qui nous
regarde,
les taux d'intérêt qui sont exigés par
les prêteurs. Et donc, il y a un moment
où il y aura un déclic, j'en suis
intimement persuadé et il faut espérer
qu'à ce moment-là un homme, une femme de
recours puisse s'emparer
de ce qui est vacant dans notre pays.
c'est-à-dire de cette lueur d'espoir et
en face un phare pour que le pays
s'éclaire, se réveille et comprenne
qu'il faut réformer de façon extrêmement
rigoureuse et très profonde
ce qui s'est délité au fil du temps et
qui a fait que notre pays à force
d'accorder de plus en plus de droits
individuels
au aux citoyens les uns les autres autre
euh ne défend plus l'intérêt général,
n'a plus les outils. En tout cas, la
justice par exemple n'accepte pas que
l'autorité s'exerce euh que ce soit pour
des règles de sécurité dans les rues,
que ce soit pour les droits
que qu'acquier et dont disposent ceux
qui entreprennent. Quand vous
construisez un ouvrage important, un
ouvrage de transport ou bien un ouvrage
énergétique,
il suffit que un individu soulève tel ou
tel point pour que on arrête ce qui
évidemment sert l'intérêt général du
pays d'un très grand nombre. Et donc ça
ne peut plus durer et et cette réforme
profonde, elle va tout d'un coup
apparaître comme une évidence avant que
le pays ne finisse euh de connaître
cette chute qui n'en qui n'en finit pas.
Mais ça n'est pas que des réformes
nationales qu'il faut faire, c'est aussi
revoir ce qui au niveau européen euh
bride les réformes que nous voudriions
conduire, c'est-à-dire la prééminence la
prééminence du droit européen sur le
droit français. On peut avec des
dispositions, notamment une révision
constitutionnelle, limiter ce poids. Et
puis il faut aussi que la France
travaille plus sur le plan politique,
notamment dans les institutions
européennes où euh bah nos voisins
allemands, Henry Pleiot vient de le
dire, ont sont toujours à la manœuvre,
beaucoup bossent beaucoup plus que nos
élus. leur représentation euh à
Bruxelles est beaucoup plus active que
la nôtre, mais le lobbying de nos
propres entreprises est insuffisant à
Bruxelles. Il faut il faut y aller, il
faut se défendre et il faut faire comme
les autres et le faire encore un petit
peu mieux pour qu'on remonte la pente.
Et si j'en conviens volontiers, ce que
je vous dis repose sur une espérance,
mais j'y crois qui fait que de toute
manière, il y a un moment où on sera
descendu tellement bas, les conséquences
seront tellement lourdes pour nos
compatriotes qu'il y aura il y aura un
réveil.
Non, mais les conséquences, ça va se
matérialiser comment ? Et bien c'est
déjà c'est déjà là euh la sécurité, le
pouvoir d'achat, la baisse des revenus
des ménages français par rapport au
ménage des autres pays de l'Union
européenne, encore davantage par rapport
aux États-Unis d'Amérique qui défendent
leurs intérêts alors que l'Europe ne
défend pas les intérêts des citoyens,
des États défend pas ses intérêts parce
qu'elle s'est fait infiltrer, parce
qu'il y a des gens à la manœuvre, c'est
parce qu'ils sont
Il est pas exclu que l'Union européenne
Il n'est pas exclu que l'Union
européenne dont la naissance a été
imaginé aux États-Unis euh
se montre complaisante avec
nos alliés qui sont un peu flagolants
actuellement américains et les
Américains ne se sont jamais gênés pour
tirer les avantages de la force du
dollar de l'extraterritorialité de leur
droit. Encore récemment, madame Van
Derleyen
s'est couché pour accepter que l'Europe
achète des sommes pharamineuses, je
crois, plus de 700 milliards de dollars
de gaz liquéfié ou de produits
énergétiques, ce qui est plus dangereux
parce que ça ça ouvre la porte
à la dimension nucléaire de la même
façon que le réarmement des États de de
l'Union. Euh c'est un réarbement qui
pour les Américains consiste à ce que
ces Étatsmembres au lieu de se
coordonner pour bâtir une industrie de
défense européenne avec une certaine
souveraineté et bien achète des armes
aux Américains. Il faut ouvrir les yeux,
il faut le dire et les Français sont
intelligents. Il y a eu une longue
période d'endormissement mais il faut et
on le va se réveiller.
Mais les Français sont intelligents. Il
y a une chute du cuit. Le niveau
scolaire se vaut.
Pas une chute du cuit, une chute du
niveau d'enseignement. Oui,
c'est surtout ça et c'est ça le problème
parce que notre système d'enseignement,
quelle est sa faiblesse ? Il a été
infiltré par les syndicats. C'est pas le
ministre de l'éducation qui dirige
l'éducation nationelle, ce sont les
syndicats. C'est eux qui valide les
promotions, les affectations, les
mutations. Et évidemment, les programmes
ont reflété un laisser aller.
Et ces syndicats ont accepté une
dévalorisation du salaire des
enseignants qui est évidemment quelque
chose d'extrêmement préoccupant au
bénéfice d'objectifs qui sont des
idéologiques et politiques dont on voit
aujourd'hui les conséquences dans dans
la dégradation dans les classements
bizarres. Henri,
je je crains d'abander totalement dans
ce que dit
quand on est grand patron qu'on voit des
gens débarquer, on les recrute comment ?
Bon, d'abord quand on est grand patron
enfin faut faut soyons en simpliste et
simple, on ne recrute pas tellement, on
délègue le recrutement. On recrute
quelques grands responsables mais pour
le reste c'est le système qui se met en
marche et qui au fond fait l'essentiel
et on le recrute en fonction fond
essentiellement d'un d'un parcours d'un
traicord d'un CV.
Bon, mais il y a encore dans ce pays des
enseignements supérieurs de très grande
qualité, des grandes écoles qui forment
des gens
présumé être compétents et euh et dont
le dont le cursus bon peut-être
considéré comme adapté au aux ambitions.
ce que je le plus au fond, c'est
je trouve enfin on critique beaucoup la
classe politique, je suis le premier à
le dire.
Considérant que il y a il y a en le
talent un peu fuit ce domaine. Enfin,
c'est constaté que quand on regardait la
classe politique d'il y a 30 ans 40 ans
et qu'on compare à celle d'aujourd'hui
alors pardon je comme elle comme un une
vieille chose mais mais bon on est quand
même frappé de la de la de la
dégénérescence. Bon,
mais mais de la même manière euh c'est
une crise au fond, je trouve qu'on vit
une crise de
des élites. Quand on regarde les
économiques, euh il y a pas beaucoup de
grands euh capitaines d'industrie ou de
grands
euh créateur fondateur d'empire dans
notre univers. Euh la France d' 30 ans
était beaucoup plus riche.
personnage
pourrait les énumérer ou les citer.
Qu'est-ce qui fait ça ? Alors,
probablement des règles ou des
habitudes.
La même vis mise de la finance sur le
monde économique
probablement la technocratie
aussi. Enfin, il faut lucidement
regarder les choses en se posant des
questions. Qu'est-ce qui fait que
et on sera amené à trouver des réponses.
Alors bon, ces réponses, on les a tous
plus ou moins intégré
intellectuellement, mais mais il reste à
voir comment on peut les les mettre en
pratique aujourd'hui. quand vous
regardez un conseil d'administration
et et bon vous voyez qu'un conseil
d'administration c'est une chambre
où on se complet dans une espèce de
euh reproduction sociale et puis vous
délègue à des comités théodules alors le
comité machin, le comité chose et cetera
le conseil ne réfléchit même plus à la
stratégie, il écoute les rapports des
comités. Alors le comité d'éthique, le
comité des risques, le comité de ceci,
le comité de cela. Comme si on pouvait
fabriquer une empire industriel, un
empire tout court, une aventure
industrielle sans risque.
C'est la négation de l'entreprise
et c'est pourtant les règles du jeu qui
sont aujourd'hui imposées d'une
entreprise côté.
Donc il faut se poser des questions
quand on voit l'émergence et la force
compris
les fonds d'investissement dans la vie
économique, c'estàd au fond il disposent
des principaux actifs. Bon ces gens-là
les font en question qui n'ont aucune
qui pas propriétaires des capitaux qui
qui empruntent des capitaux qui qui
collèguent des capitaux pour investir
dans des actifs. Leur seule ambition
c'est de revendre plus cher ce qu'ils
ont acheté le jour J.
N + 4 ou + 5. Donc
le court termisme euh
la pure dimension financière,
l'exclusive dimension financière tue
l'initiative, tue la créativité, tue
l'industrie et ça euh il faut en être
conscient.
Alors, être conscient, c'est déjà la
première étape, faire la correction
qu'il faut faire et puis voir peut-être
des règles du jeu qui au fond rebattent
les cartes, qui remettent au centre du
sujet justement l'esprit d'initiative,
euh
la capacité à prendre des décisions, euh
l'aventure industrielle, le long terme
parce qu'on il n'y a pas d'aventure
industrielle sans sans intégrer
la durée. Bon, on peut pas limiter à 2 3
ans avoir des rendements attendus à deux
chiffres dans un investissement à 3 ans.
C'est pas possible.
Euh donc la défaillance en matière de
recherche et développement et on voit
les règles du jeu imposées par les
anglo-saxon aux entreprises côté
européennes
étouffer je la sphère européenne
industrielle et économique
au profit des États où là c'est pas du
tout les mêmes règles du jeu. Pas du
tout.
Quand vous voyez les grandes aventures
des des grands acteurs de la nouvelle
économie industrielle américaine, il
sont pas du tout dirigé ni par des
financiers ni par des fonds et euh il
bénéficient de subventions considérables
de la part de l'État appu des services
de renseignement ou d'ancien cadre du
renseignement
entre autres pas uniquement. Et donc on
est dans dans dans une espèce de
on se complet dans une espèce de
quiétude
parce qu'au fond euh
peut-être que c'est plus confortable de
ne pas avoir d'ambition.
Confortable, rassurant,
mais ouais, rassurant peut-être pas,
mais enfin en tout cas confortable.
confortable pour les décideurs en tout
cas parce que eux euh quand vous voyez
que dans les banques, prenons juste
l'exemple du système bancaire,
le nombre de millionnaires
euh c'està dire de gens gagnant plus
d'un million d'euros euh dans les
banques a été mais mais démultiplié de
manière considérable au cours des
dernières années.
regarder dans l'industrie le nombre de
millionnaires dans l'industrie de de
salariés millionnaires dans l'industrie
parce qu'on ti d'une main
donc font pourquoi faire pourquoi est-ce
que les talent dans l'industrie ils
auront plus dans la finance
et donc on a les meilleurs esprits qui
se consacrent à justement détruire la
logique en favorisant le temps court la
spéculation la création purement
monétaire et pas du tout industrielle au
détriment de justement justement des
fondamentaux.
C'est intéressant le coût de la création
monétaire au détriment de de réels
actifs, la création magique
ou
monétaire. Bernard,
quand on se retrouve avec de l'argent
magique, de l'énergie magique, de la
dette, ce qui est l'équivalent de
l'énergie promise ou future ou bientôt
exploitée, mais qui n'est pas sonnante
et trébuchante, la France a 3300
milliards de dette. Notre président de
la République, ce lumineux, cet astre
grandissant
avec son ministre des finances, Bruno
Lemer, nous ont rajouté 1300 milliards
pour les dépenses courantes avec un
investissement sur le long terme qui est
très discutable.
nos députés l'Assemblée nationale
il se complaisait dans le rondron
quotidien à s'échanger des des petits
mots sur l'écume des choses où ils ont
conscience qu'un pays comme la France,
il faut un cap, une stratégie à long
terme.
Je je vais revenir sur le ce qui me
paraît le plus important, c'est
je vous y autorise.
C'est sur le long terme.
Je suis magnanime aujourd'hui
le long terme. Henri Progliot a a
déploré à juste titre que il est devenu
de plus en plus difficile dans une
entreprise quelle qu'elle soit
d'essayer d'avoir un projet de long
terme parce que c'est les billatetés sur
les profits rapides et cetera. C'est
pareil en politique, il n'y a pas moyen
d'avoir un projet de long terme tel que
a été
le projet Besmer, c'est-à-dire le plan
Besmer. C'est un projet qui s'est allé
sur euh un demi-siècle, hein, et même
plus euh pas loin d'un siècle. Euh c'est
plus possible. Et bien ça, il faut
trouver le moyen d'y revenir. Je pense
que euh dans une démocratie, pour se
faire élire, il faut promettre la Lune.
Ouais. Jouer de la flûte.
Il faut il faut dire voilà, on va
engager telle ou telle nouvelle dépenses
et vous aurez le président du pouvoir
vous aurez tel ou tel
avantage supplémentaire. Sauf qu'on a
pas l'argent pour financer tout cela. Et
c'est ce qui crée notre dette, hein.
Lorsque certains partis politiques
disent "Bon bon, on va revenir sur la
réforme des retraites." Euh c'est
totalement irresponsable. C'est pas un
point de vue politique, c'est juste une
question de d'arithmétique.
Et donc il faut avoir le courage de
reconnaître qu'il y a quatre problèmes
le long terme pour lequel il faudrait
qu'on institue une sorte de nouveau
moyen de légiférer qui s'imposerait dans
le temps et qui jigeraient des majorités
qualifiées peut-être des deux assemblées
pour être remis en cause sur des très
grands projets, l'énergie notamment en
État. Et puis il y a trois sources
de déficit et qui creusent la dette à
une vitesse phénoménale. La première,
c'est évidemment la question des
retraites lorsque en 1983,
l'âge légal de la retraite est rapporté
de 80 de 65 à 60 ans d'un seul coup. Les
caisses sont naturellement excédentaires
pour les raisons démographiques. On sait
qu'elles vont devenir euh défidéaire
dans un certain nombre d'années. Il
aurait fallu à ce moment-là créer fonds
de pension français qui auraient permis
une capitalisation nationale et qui
aurait évité que les plus beaux joyaux
industriels français soient de plus en
plus entre la main d'actionnaire
étranger. Donc la question premier poste
de de grand déficit, c'est les retraites
en France où on travaille moins
qu'ailleurs au cours de la vie. Ensuite,
il y a le la couverture maladie. Je
connais bien, je suis médecin, j'ai
exercé de très nombreuses années. Il n'y
a aucun aucun clapet. C'est-à-dire que
que l'on soit pauvre, que l'on soit
riche, euh c'est 100 % remboursé si on a
une mutuelle qu'il faut encore pouvoir
se payer. Mais ça c'est
déresponsabilisant et c'est un problème.
Il faut trouver le moyen de
responsabiliser pour que euh la chance
que l'on a disposé du système de soins
euh que l'on a encore aujourd'hui, mais
peut-être pas pour très longtemps,
puisse être pérénisé car le pays
vieillit, les traitements sont de plus
en plus chers mais ils sont de plus en
plus efficaces, les progrès sont
fabuleux. Je n'ai jamais cessé de suivre
les progrès de la science médicale, des
traitements. C'est c'est magnifique et
c'est merveilleux. Mais mais mais il
faut il faut l'assumer. Je vais terme 3è
point 3è source de déficit, ce sont les
collectivités locales. J'été maire 31
ans. Les collectivités locales, elles
ont augmenté leurs effectifs de
fonctionnaires territoriaux de 50 % en
20 ans. Pendant ce temps-là, tout a été
numérisé, automatisé, simplifié et donc
là, il y a un problème. Voilà les trois.
Il faut avoir le courage de regarder ces
trois sujets et de trouver des moyens
pour réduire réduire la dette. Voilà. En
tout cas ce qui crée qui crée les
déficits et ce qui crée la dette. 3
C'était quoi ma question ?
Vous avez eu ma réponse.
Vous êtes politique vous ? Non.
J'ai un petit passé.
Non mais rappelez-moi votre question. Je
vais y
Vous avez fait votre thèse sur quoi ?
Ah j'ai fait ma thèse sur
Ah ben vous avez vous avez tort. Je vais
vous le dire parce que ben
non parce que vous êtes foutu de ma
question.
Je vais vous le dire sur quoi j'ai fait
ma thèse ? J'ai fait ma thèse sur
l'implantation des sour profonds et
totaux par
sour profond et
et et complet total laurdité totale par
l'implantation cocléaire. Et c'est moi
qui ai imaginé et je le dis publiquement
l'électrode multicanal qui est implanté
partout qui a été j'ai révélé la
technique qui maintenant est implantée
partout dans le monde. J'ai pas pris de
brevet. J'étais trop jeune. Mon patron à
l'époque m'a dit "Non, non, Bernard,
c'est pas la peine. J'aurais j'aurais eu
une autre j'aurais eu" Il s'appelait
Charrachon, je je j'aurais eu une autre
vie, mais je suis très content de la vie
que j'ai eu. Donc, je tenais à vous dire
ça parce que là aussi en politique, là
aussi en politique, il faudrait avoir
davantage
de gens qui s'engagent en politique et
qui ont fait autre chose dans leur vie.
les politiques que vous avez été amené à
cornaquer ou du moins surveillé comme un
un pion à l'école parce que maintenant
l'Assemblée nationale ça ressemble un
peu à la cour des miracles. Non, ça
s'invective, ça connaît pas les
dossiers. C'est l'Assemblée nationale
qui dérive. C'est l'Assemblée nationale
qui dérive. Et euh
pourquoi aujourd'hui il y a pas de
sanction ? C'est parce que le bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale qui est l'autorité
composée d'un certain nombre de
représentants des différents groupes qui
peut prononcer les sanctions
est majoritairement
entre les mains d'une opposition
extrêmement radicale, je pense en
particulier à LI parce que certains ne
sont pas allés voter
au moment où on composait le bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale. C'est le groupe
Renaissance qui n'était pas content de
ce qui était passé. ils sont pas allés
voter et du coup on a un bureau qui
empêche la présidence de l'Assemblée
nationale de prononcer les sanctions si
en sont indispensables parce que l'image
que donne aujourd'hui l'Assemblée
nationale ne peut que dégoûter les
Français de la vie politique de leurs
élites. C'est vrai queon a plus des
débats du niveau qui existaient il y a
20 30 ou 40 ans dans l'hémicycle, mais
il y avait il y a encore matière à faire
des débats de fond et aller sur qualité
d'échange qui soit rassurante pour les
Français. Henry, quand j'entends
Bernard, quand il arrive à entendre mes
questions ou à essayer d'y répondre ou à
essayer de me fourguer sa cam de
politique,
quand on a une stratégie industrielle,
quel est quel est votre point de vue sur
notre représentation nationale ?
Honnêtement,
vous en tant que capitaine d'industrie,
grand capitaine d'industrie, quand vous
mettez LCP, très bonne chaîne de télé de
temps en temps et que vous voulez
regarder avec un pion au milieu, vous
vous dites "On marche sur la tête, on a
les politiques qu'on mérite, c'est
vraiment ils sont à bleu au possible,
ils aiment se faire réir, ils s'écoutent
parler et en fait à l'intérieur c'est le
grand vide.
Moi, j'ai toujours respect particulier
pour
pour le politique au sens étymologique
du terme parce que
d'abord ça fait partie des valeurs qui
m'ont été inculquées. D'autre part, j'ai
pendant toute ma vie professionnelle
dans le service public et donc dans le
service public, les interlocuteurs
naturellement sont des élus. Bon
et je dois dire que j'ai trouvé dans euh
je dirais le le spectre des élus locaux
ou quel que soit leur tendance politique
d'ailleurs des gens de très bonne
qualité. Ce que je déplore au fond,
c'est que les évolutions récentes ont
cassé une dynamique assez naturelle,
c'est-à-dire
notamment
rendant à César ce qui lui appartient,
la décision d'Hollande du mandat unique
a coupé l'Assemblée nationale de ses
racines. C'estàd il était naturel
d'avoir des gens qui étaient députés
maire, sénateur maire qui avaient donc
un pied dans le réel dans les
collectivités locales qui avaient le
contact avec la population qui était
qui étaient des je dirais des gens
responsables. J'allais dire des
professionnels, c'est pas le terme, des
gens responsables qui avaient au fond un
contact et et un contact responsable
avec le peuple. le vrai peuple. Bon, le
fait d'avoir coupé cette ces racines,
c'est-à-dire d'avoir imposé à ces élusl
de choisir entre eux leur
responsabilités d'élus locaux et leur
responsabilité des nationaux fait que la
plupart de ceux qui étaient engagés dans
la vie politique locale dans notamment
dans les vies grandes et moyennes ont
préféré rester auprès de leurs habitants
et ont abandonné leur responsabilité
nationale et qu'on a à l'assemblée
particulièrement à l'assemblée bon
nombre de gens Bon,
on se demande ce qu'il foutent là
sans racine, déraciné euh
et qui au fond se sentent un peu et et
qui n'ont pas le contact avec les les le
les les citoyens du quotidien.
Cette décision aussi
qui était d'ailleurs absurde en terme
économique puisque ça a conduit à
augmenter le nombre d'élus de manière
considérable. les élus locaux qui
avaient une position de parlementaire
national avait de toute façon un plafond
de rémunération qui faisait qu'il
gagnait pas de fois la même chose.
qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup plus en
nombre d'élus euh et donc des coûts
beaucoup plus importants puisque puisque
le plafonnement ne joue pas
et on a une assemblée largement
déracinée largement
je dirais à l'écart du bon
et ça se sent
donc euh ça se sent par les dérives
d'ailleurs, ne serait-ce que parce que
les gens qui ont des responsabilités
locales ils sont plus mesurés dans leur
dans leur position euh parce qu'ils ont
une population bah composite par
euh
donc je regrette je regrette vraiment
que cette décision il faudra y revenir
il il faudra faudra la dénoncer et je
vois pas pourquoi on continue
et comme le le les gens ne sont pas
informés ils considèrent qu'il est
légitime
ou que le mandat unique, il est
plébiscité par le peuple parce qu'on
leur on leur explique pas les choses. Et
donc le mandat unique, c'est une plie
absolu pour la démocratie
aujourd'hui en France. Clairement quand
on entend Bernard dire il faut défendre
la France, il faut défendre
c'est ça sonne bien à l'oreille c'est
c'est du miel pour mes oreilles.
Défendre c'est bien mais la meilleure
stratégie c'est l'attaque.
C'est se préparer, se prépositionner,
bondir, mordre, avancer en meute. Quand
on est capitaine d'industrie, est-ce
qu'on a l'État qui vient vous aider à
chasser en meute, à être agressif,
percutant, perforant ?
Merci Henri.
La réponse est non. Bon non mais
j'essaie de Ouais, la réponse est non
parce que
d'abord qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
de quoi est-ce qu'on parle ? Quel est
qu'est-ce que c'est l'État ?
C'est nous
Non mais ça c'est pas nous. L'État ce
sont des fonctionnaires essentiellement,
c'est pas des élus.
Ce qu'on appelle l'État, c'est d'avoir
des administrations
euh
qui n'ont aucune vision de ce qui est le
monde économique, mais aucune.
Je dis pas qu'ils sont mal rationné,
mais ils sont ils sont
je
dans le rond quotidien
non dans des dans des je obsessions ou
des
des visions déformées de la réalité.
Et puis
quand on parle d'économie, d'industrie
et cetera, on parle du monde. On parle
pas de la France, on parle pas d'un
monde isolé, on parle pas d'un monde
limité au territoire hexagonal. Et donc
quand on va à la concrète du marché des
marchés internationaux, on voit bien que
l'État français est totalement
en dehors en dehors du réel.
Donc on se bat tout seul, on se bat
contre des concurrents qui eux ont je
dirais
un appareil d'état derrière,
un appareil d'État qui les protège, qui
les a et nous on est dans un état un
état curieux parce que
parce qu'on état policier au fond,
un état
dirait
intransige et exigeant enfin
Euh voyez le fisque, vous voyez leurs
voyez
euh l'ensemble des organisation
d'étatique qui au fond traque
l'entreprise comme si c'était
l'adversaire
de la part de qui ?
De certains chefs d'entreprise.
Bon, il y en a eu il en aura toujours
enfin des abus méritent d'être les abus
méritent d'être sansionnés. C'est pas le
sujet. Le sujet c'est de pas être
soupçonné d'abus alors qu'on est
simplement
le pied au plancher.
Oui. Enfin on est simplement bien
intentionné. Je bon je critique pas les
syndicats. Moi je trouve que
ça on reconnaît bien le patron de DF.
Oui faut j'étais patron de Volodia
pendant longtemps avant d'être patron de
DF. Non, mais
quand on gère des entreprises avec un
nombre important de salariés, on a
besoin de d'organisations
avec lesquelles on discute, avec
lesquelles on on se met d'accord ou pas
d'ailleurs. Mais euh les corps
intermédiaires ça existe, ils ont on en
a besoin. Bon, les syndicats ont cette
vocation. Donc je diabolise pas les
syndicats. Les syndicats bon bah ils
défendent, ils sont ils sont là pour
défendre les salariés quand ils abusent.
On peut le dénoncer
mais d'expérience
au fond. Je vais vous dire une
chose telle que je j'ai vécu dans des
dizaines d'années. J'ai jamais eu de
problème avec les syndicats parce qu'au
fond
on a un discours sans complaisance, des
discussions qui était parfois un peu
virile mais qui conduisait à des à des à
des conclusions qui étaient ou pas
positives ou négatives mais mais on
pouvait éventuellement on pouvait
discuter.
En tant que j'ai eu au fond plus de
support des syndicats que eu de l'État.
Curieusement.
Non, c'est pas curieux.
Parce que le syndicat il tenait
l'entreprise,
les salariés tiennent à leur entreprise.
Ils ont envie que l'entreprise
réussisse. Il ont pas envie qu'elle
coule. Quand vous prenez les gens
au fond des difficultés, des problèmes,
on peut parler. L'État, il est
irresponsable.
des administrations qui connaissent pas
l'entreprise
et donc je préfère discuter avec des
syndicats qu'à l'administration
parce que bon prenez prenez
l'administration fiscale bon c'est c'est
un univers en soi. Vous appliquez la
loi, on vous dit vous avez un abus un
abus de droit. Mais j'ai appliqué la
loi. Oui mais vous appliquez trop la
loi.
D'accord. Moi je l'applique. Je Si vous
voulez changer la loi, changez-la.
Je ne fais qu'appliquer la loi. Oui,
mais vous l'appliquez trop.
C'est absurde. On est dans un univers
qui parfois confine à l'absurde. Il y a
plus de logique.
Avec un syndicat, vous êtes en
désaccord. Vous êtes un désaccord. Vous
dites "OK, il une grève, très bien, on
affronte la réalité. Là, non, on a on
affronte des fantasmes et et au fond, ce
pays ultra technocratisé." C'est-à-dire
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup trop de
fonctionnaires, beaucoup trop de gens
qui font appliquer des textes qui ne
comprennent même pas dont ils n'ont pas
conscience de la portée et qui se
contentent au fond euh
d'attaquer l'entreprise comme si c'était
un adversaire. Non.
Donc je je
suis navré de voir l'importance qu'après
la finance et qu'après l'administration
dans un univers économique normal où ni
les salariés ni les entrepreneurs
n'ont plus de comment dira de
crédibilité
et ça c'est embêtant.
Bernard fait mal d'entendre ça non ?
Comment
ça fait mal d'entendre ça ?
C'est la vérité.
C'est la vérité. Il y a une
une distance énorme entre l'appareil
d'État et l'appareil productif,
c'est-à-dire les entreprises, les chefs
d'entreprise.
Ce sont deux mondes qui malheureusement
n'échangent pas assez et par conséquent
[Musique]
s'il n'échange pas et bien il
s'affrontent.
Vous avez été à la REF tous les deux là
cette année ?
Moi j'y suis pas allé.
Le la colonie de vacances du MEDF ?
Non.
Donc c'est c'est un c'est un énorme
problème et ça aussi il faudrait qu'il y
ait un travail qui soit fait de façon
extrêmement durable pour faire en sorte
que l'administration
protège notre système de production. En
fait, la richesse du pays, c'est juste
ce qu'on produit et la
désindustrialisation
galopante de la France est un problème
dramatique. Et à ce sujet, ce qui est en
train de se passer sur l'industrie
automobile euh avec la décision
européenne d'interdire la fabrication et
la vente de voiture à moteur thermique
dès 2035 et est un mais c'est c'est un
séisme qu'on est en train de construire.
C'est un séisme.
Bon, je pense que l'Europe est victime
de
d'un lobbing très efficace qu'a fait
qu'a fait l'Asie dans ce domaine au
fond. La grande enfin l'une des
principales industries européennes,
c'est l'industrie automobile évidemment
l'Allemagne en premier et cette décision
technocratique
absurde
issue d'ailleurs
des partis écoles hein euh
fait la fortune de la Chine et et et le
et et le drame de de l'industrie
européenne.
Bernard ? Oui. Oui. Euh c'est
intéressant d'essayer de comprendre
comment on en est arrivé là et euh comme
l'a dit tout à l'heure Henry Progliot,
le rôle de l'écologie politique euh avec
des accointances qui sont extrêmement
sulfureuses, en particulier les liens de
l'écologie politique avec les grandes
ONG internationales dont le financement
est lui aussi tout à fait sulfureux.
C'est cette écologie politique a su
pousser
des décisions au niveau européen par un
lobbying
acharné et des et des ONG qui sont
financés par l'Europe par nos propres
impôts à des décisions complètement
folles. Je pense bien entendu
aux impératifs en matière de réduction
d'hypothétique réduction de gaz
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre qui
sont inatténables. Si on veut réduire
les gaz à effet de serre, il faut avoir
une démarche rationnelle. Il faut pas
l'imposer par le haut. Il faut voir
comment on peut notamment disposer d'une
électricité la moins chère possible et
non pas renchérie parce que on
subventionne à perte des des productions
paréoliennes et photophotoïques euh qui
qui coûtent les yeux de la tête aux
États et aux consommateurs. Donc le prix
de l'énergie évidemment est extrêmement
important et les écolos ont bien compris
pour conduire à la décroissance et bien
on rend l'énergie de plus en plus chère,
on la rend si possible aléatoire
c'estàdire qu'il va falloir mettre son
four et faire marcher les machines quand
il y aura de l'électricité
sinon ça sera tellement cher que il y
aura plus aucune compétitivité
possiblecher. Il faud il faudra
débrancher les vieux aussi ou pas ?
Ça c'est un autre sujet que l'écologie
politique n'a pas encore abordé. Euh
puis elle serait tardé,
ça c'est par le biais des dépenses
sociales hein parce que il n'a pas été
anticipé dans dans un certain nombre de
pays dont la France le vieillissement de
la population. Mais mais restons si vous
voulez un instant, si vous me le
permettez, sur
les conséquences
de de l'activisme de l'écologie
politique au niveau européen comme cela
a été dit tout à l'heure évidemment en
Allemagne mais aussi en France parce que
les normes qui écrasent notre
agriculture qui écrasent
les projets d'aménagement de
construction d'infrastr structure. Tout
ça a été poussé par l'écologie
politique. L'écologie politique
instrumentalise les peurs pour que et
bien les politiques se croient obligés
de compliquer les normes j'ai vécu en
tant que président de groupe
parlementaire, j'ai vécu
républicain comment c'était quoi ?
Oui, j'étais à l'époque président du du
groupe UMP. J'ai vécu
l'introduction qui était groupe
majoritaire à l'assemblée
SarkoZi quoi
non c'était c'était Chirak à l'époque et
j'ai vu j'ai vécu l'introduction dans la
constitution du principe de précaution
ça a été une grave erreur. J'ai essayé
je dois dire que je n'ai pas réussi et
que ma fois je je me suis soumis. J'ai
essayé de dissuader Jacques Chirac mais
Jacques Chirac avait été marabouté par
Nicolas Hul qui lui avait expliqué que
le principe de précaution
marabouté
marabouté manipulé convaincu
qu'il fallait faire ça
pour avoir de l'électorat.
Non
non non. Jacques Chira qui était un
personnage qui fonctionnait aussi au
feeling. Il avait été
convaincu et puis son entourage familial
avait probablement acquiessé. et et et
donc et c'est une supputation et euh et
il l'a imposé, on l'a mis dans la
Constitution. C'était parfaitement
inutile parce que c'est déjà dans une
déctive européenne qui s'impose au droit
français, c'est déjà dans la loi Barnier
et là on l'a mis dans la constitution.
Et bien que s'est-il passé récemment ?
Récemment, le Conseil constitutionnel a
argumenté à partir du principe de
précaution pour interdire l'usage d'un
pesticide de façon extrêmement compe.
D'ailleurs, un pesticide dont la la
toxicité encore une fois est ciblée,
encadrée et et nous aurons ça va
s'imposer une catastrophe dans
l'industrie dans l'agriculture et dans
l'industrie sucère française. Donc si
vous voulez pan par pan l'écologie
politique
met à tout ce qui conduit à produire,
c'est-à-dire à produire des richesses
agricoles, industrielles. Euh je vais me
faire avoquer du diable Bernard. Euh
vous qui êtes tout bib euh vous vous
rendez bien compte que certaines
molécules euh qui sont immortelles
finissent dans nos pratique. Alors des
fois il y a d'autres autres molécules
qui finissent dans nos pratiques, des
matières ficales et on en passé des
meilleurs. Et ça conduit à avoir de
l'eau en bouteille
de source mais qui en fait est filtré
autant que l'eau du robinet. L'avocat du
diable dit quand même le principe de
précaution, il y a des choses
Non non non, attendez justement en
réalité on connaît la toxicité d'un
certain nombre de molécules. On n pas
on n pas on n pas attenduie
pardon
un peu comme les essais nucléaires de de
Gaul et de Chirac en Polynésie on
connaissait.
Oui mais là encore les conséquences si
vous voulez tout est question de seuil.
Nous vivons depuis toujours dans un
milieu hostile. Le problème, c'est qu'il
faut que le le le risque soit euh
inférieur aux avantages et on a un
nombre
très élevé de réglementation qui ont
fixé des seuils parce que des produits
toxiques, il y en a absolument partout.
Et le progrès aussi fait queil y a
autour de nous des produits toxiques.
Mais
donc le projet de la géopolitique
nécessitait des essais nucléaire en
Polynésie qui à sacrifier un peu les
Polynésiens parce que sinon on
pas sacrifié les Polynésiens. Ça c'est
une c'est c'est faux hein. Alors il y a
eu des essais nucléaires qui ont été
effectivement
réalisés en Polynésie. Bon, depuis un
certain nombre d'initiatives qui ont été
pris pour d'abord en mesurer les
conséquences et ensuite indemniser un
certain nombre de secteurs. Mais mais
c'est pas un problème majeur de la même
manière que ce que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure, c'est-à-dire ce que habilement
l'écologie politique a baptisé des
polluants éternels. Ils sont pas
éternels. C'est vrai, ils restent très
longtemps dans la nature, mais ils sont
pas éternels. C'est comme ça que
fonctionne l'écologie politique. Elle
manipule les termes, elle manipule les
peurs, elle instrumentalise les peurs de
manière à paralyser et aboutir à une
société de décroissance qui est qui est
son rêve. Mais l'épiface, il y en a des
milliers. Et l'épipace, il y en a
certains la molécule en question
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure qui
sont effectivement toxiques. On les a
identifié, on en mesure les seuils. Ils
ont été élimés dans un certain nombre de
process industriels et d'autres qui
n'ont pas une toxicité importante.
Ensuite, il y a des solutions. S'il y a
hélas une pollution, on peut traiter ses
eaux avec des charbons actifs et on
éliminide ses pifac. Donc c'est toujours
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure, la
place des sciences, il y a toujours une
une solution scientifique. Et
d'ailleurs, si les sciences malgré tous
ces produits qu'on nous prétend
extrêmement toxique euh était euh pas ce
qu' qu'ils le sont, comment expliquer
que l'espérance de vie a augmenté comme
elle a augmenté et l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé. En réalité, le juge arbitre
c'est cela. Et jusqu'à présent et bien
en France tout ce qui a été fait malgré
ce qu'on entend que nous soyons nous
serions empoisonnés du soir au matin et
du matin au soir, tout ça tout ça c'est
une vaste manipulation. Je ne dis pas
qu'il n'y a pas des produits toxices, je
ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas les
travailler et avancer encore, mais tout
arrêter et bien on va s'apauvrir et pour
avoir un meilleur environnement, pour
avoir une meilleure santé, ben il faut
avoir des moyens.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Est-ce qu'il y a
une recrudessescence du concert de
Colomb chez les gamins de moins de 10
ans ? Je n'en ai pas je n'ai pas cette
connaissance.
Il est clair qu'avec l'allongement de
l'espérance de vie, l'incidence des
cancers qui sont aussi liés à la
longueur de la vie augmentent. Mais les
progrès qui sont effectués dans le
traitement des cancers sont aussi
spectaculaires. Un certain nombre de
mélanomes qui autrefois étaient à tout
coup mortel, pas tous, mais maintenant
une nombre d'entre eux ont les guérit.
Quand j'ai commencé mes études de
médecine, le cancer du poumon était à
tout coup mortel ou pratiquement.
Maintenant, une grande partie d'entre
eux bénéficie de traitement qui ont été
inventés, développés depuis quelques
années et qui les guérissent. Il y a un
chanteur célèbre, Florent Pagny, qui en
est l'exemple vivant.
En espérant que il soit remis jusqu'au
bout. Henri, est-ce que on peut avoir
des mesures, des préconisations
pour les 12 prochains mois ?
Euh Bernard nous parle de découvrir un
homme ou une femme providentielle. Bon,
est-ce qu'il faut sortir de l'Europe ?
Est-ce qu'il faut [__] Macron à la
porte et à tout sa bande de de président
de BDE fier d'être amateur ? Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait là ?
Je je n'ai pas
de réponse particulière. Je moi je suis
un spectateur attentif du monde
politique. Je je n'en fais pas partie
comme vous le savez. Euh
je l'attente populaire est est est est
est est est est est
palpable. Je au fond. Euh
est-ce qu'
tu penses que les gens ont envie
euh d'être consulté ? Je pense mais
c'est un avis,
c'est un constat que je fais euh
maintenant qu'est-ce que donnerai une
consultation ? Euh j'en sais rien.
Il suffit de lire les les articles, les
les les sondages et cetera pour en avoir
une idée. Mais mais rester dans cette
situation
euh bout de
au fond de
d'incertitude, découragement et et
de doute n'est pas de nature à renforcer
le moral. C'est donc euh le retournement
de l'économie.
Bernard ?
Ah, personnellement
on sort de l'Europe.
Non, on va pas sortir de l'Europe
d'abord, c'est c'est ce serait
excessivement compliqué et il faut et il
faut voir aussi ce que l'Europe a
apporté et apporte de positif. Mais par
contre, qu'il faille réformer un certain
nombre de de choses en Europe, c'est une
évidence. L'Europe ne doit pas être
aujourd'hui qu'un vaste marché ouvert à
tout vent. L'Europe doit protéger
l'appareil productif
européen. C'est et c'est c'est pas c'est
pas du tout ce que l'e protège
l'appareil productif allemand là.
Oui. Et ben aussi parce que les
à peine
à peine sur l'automobile c'est pas le
cas hein.
Le
c'était satirique c'était
Non non non non. Je pense que
l'Allemagne est victime
de ses propres agissements, c'est-à-dire
que le le le le
système s'est retourné contre elle, ils
ont favorisé ce développement et que au
fond les lobby l'onté même sur l'intérêt
collectif allemand.
alors pour revenir à la question que je
et et et le vrai problème qui est
peut-on rester dans la situation où nous
sommes
en tant que citoyen, en tant que
démocrate mais aussi en tant qu'auliste,
je pense que il y a quelque chose de
très important, ce sont les institutions
que nous allégué le général de Gaulle.
Et contrairement à ce qu'on en dit, ces
institutions, elles sont solides et
c'est un régime parlementaire. On le
voit bien aujourd'hui, l'assemblée ne
marche pas. Et bien on ne peut rien
faire quand on dit que ben ma fois le
pouvoir du parlementaire est nul. C'est
faux. Ils ont le pouvoir.
Oui,
je suis d'accord.
Ils ont le pouvoir. Et donc aujourd'hui
l'assemblée ne marche pas. C'est un cas
de figure qui ne serait pas à contetemps
de prononcer une dissolution. Autant la
dissolution de Chiraak en 97 était à
contetemps, il a perdu. Autant la la
dissolution prononcée par le président
Macron en 2024
était à contetemps puisque c'était à la
suite d'une consultation européenne que
constamment les majorités en place
perdent et et il a perdu et bien
aujourd'hui le pays est incouvernable en
raison de la composition de l'assemblée
et ben il faut retourner devant le
peuple et ben faut respecter quand même
soit on est en démocratie soit on n'est
pas en démocratie mais si on est en en
démocratie on n pas peur d'aller d'aller
d'aller devant le peuple. Alors, c'est
vrai que la pensée unique ne veut pas
qu'on dissolve tout de suite. C'est vrai
que certains groupes politiques avec des
alliances qui sont pas très claires
sont pas pressés d'aller devant les
électeurs. Ben, je pars au socialistes
et alors l'alliance devant les LFI avec
LFI. De toute façon, les socialistes
retourneront avec LFI, autrement leur
groupe va fondre comme neige au soleil.
Et donc, ils sont pas pressés de montrer
cela. Mais l'intérêt du pays, c'est de
vite tirer au clair de manière à avoir
une lecture plus précise de ce qui est
la majorité de la volonté des Français.
Si ça ne pr pas plaît pas à certains nom
de Français et je peux en être et bien
malheureusement euh elle ça s'imposera.
C'est quoi ça plaît pas ? S'il y a une
majorité s'il y a une majorité, comme
l'indique comme on tendance à l'indiquer
les sondages, une majorité euh issue du
Rassemblement national, euh il y a un
nombre de Français importants qui seront
à juste titre mécontents ou inquiets.
Mais c'est la volonté du peuple et nos
institutions sont suffisamment solides
pour que ben nous vivions avec cette
situation. Est-ce que
le RN trouvera de quoi faire une
majorité ? J'en doute. En tout cas, on
avancera tandis que là, on fait du sur
place. Et l'immobilisme en toute chose,
que ce soit en médecine, que ce soit
dans l'entreprise, que ce soit dans la
vie, l'immobilisme, ce soit dans la
chasse, l'immobilisme est dangereux.
Vous avez jamais remarqué les scores du
Parti socialiste ou de l'UMMP, c'est
inversement proportionnel au coût de
l'énergie ou à la capacité à lever de la
dette pas chère. Là, on lève de la dette
chère. Et le coût de l'énergie est très
important. Donc les socialistes vont se
faire balayer
et la droite molle va se balayer.
Il restera plus que les filles ou le
Front National. Non.
Alors ma lecture n'est pas celle-ci. Et
je pense qu'à partir du moment où on
décide de d'affaiblir, voire de mettre à
mal des partis qui d'ailleurs étit
fragilisé, qui étaient des partis de
gouvernement, je pense à au Parti
socialistes ou aux républicains, ce qui
était la volonté du président de la
République actuelle. Et bien si vous
détruisez ces deux forces que l'on
appelle républicaines probablement à
juste titre, si vous si vous les
détruisez, ben vous laissez en face des
partis qui sont beaucoup plus radicaux
et c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer. Pardon ?
Les socialistes, ils font combien aux
dernières élections ? Bah il les les les
socialistes ont effectivement vu leur
électorat complètement fondre, ce qui
fait qu'ils sont divisés en deux avec
euh ce qui reste oui, je vais y venir.
Ce qui reste de de des sociau-démocrates
qui sont euh plus très nombreux et ceux
qui se tournent vers les fill
communautariste et extrémiste. Quant aux
républicains, oui, les républicains ont
vu leur électorat se diviser dans deux.
une partie est allée soutenir le
Emmanuel Macron et une autre partie
s'est tourner vers le Rassemblement
national. Mais il reste quand même chez
les Républicains
une force, un réalisme et et des
objectifs et des hommes et des femmes
qui à mon avis peuvent se réveiller
comme d'ailleurs dans la
social-démocratie à gauche
peuvent se réveiller. Il faudrait qu'ils
soient déjà réveillés là. Il y a urgence
quand même non ? Je pense qu'ils sont
réveillés, qu'ils ont essayé d'aller
plus loin.
Henriapart
vous a reproché d'avoir mangé avec
Marine Le Pen que le patronat se se se
rallie au Front National.
Moi je peux parler je ne peux pas parler
au nom du patronat. À tite personnel,
j'ai
rencontré alors déjeuner ou rencontrer
tous les
responsables de groupe parlementaires,
quel qu'il soit.
Bon, ils sont d'ailleurs
naturellement démocratiquement élus.
Vous leur avez dit quoi ?
Non, mais il voulait enfin j'ai je c'est
pas moi qui sollicite. Je je il voulait
m'interroger sur la situation de
l'industrie de l'énergie. J'ai pas de
raison de refuser.
Donc j'ai j'ai accepté de voir les uns
et les autres et de dire font mes
recommandations à la matière. C'est
tout. C'est quoi les recommandations ?
Les recommandations, vous les
connaissez. C'est au fond,
j'ai j'ai une vision assez euh
Ouais. Enfin, j'espère en tout cas en
tout cas simple des choses. On avait un
outil de production qui il y a une
quinzaine d'années permettait à la
France de disposer d'une énergie
électrique
euh de de qualité à un niveau de coût de
revient qui était le plus bas d'Europe
et qui nous mettait en situation d'être
non seulement autosuffisant mais
exportateur.
Il était avant la mode des égères
renouvelables.
On a toujours le même parc de
production.
Il est resté. On a le même parc
électronucléaire malgré la fermeture de
Fadim que je déplore mais du fait de
l'ajout de Fenville à peu près la même
capacité de production électronucléaire
qu'il y a 20 ans. On a la même capacité
de production hydraulique
les deux.
L'un représentant à peu près 75 77 % du
besoin de la France de l'époque l'autre
à peu près 12 et demi 13 %. Donc 90 % du
besoin de l'énergie française étant
encouvert par l'électronucéire d'une
part et l'hydraulique d'autre part avec
des coups de revient incomparablement
plus efficaces que les autres énergies.
Et dans tout ce spectre politique
et et pour pour les besoins de point, on
avait deux ou trois centrales euh à
charbon propre d'ailleurs puisquon les
avait reconvertis au charbon propre.
Fiou.
Non non fiou, on l'a arrêté depuis
longtemps.
C'est du charbon euh propre,
c'est-à-dire sans émission de beaucoup
de CO2. Donc on avait pratiquement une
énergie
non émétrice de CO2, un coup de revient
qui faisait de la France la référence
mondiale
et de tous ces spectres politiques
rencontrés, lesquels étaient un petit
peu plus percutants, lesquels étaient
plus sensibles ou à la trajectoire ? qui
on posé les meilleures questions ou
est-ce que c'était simplement le
rondrond ? Non, c'est pas le rondrond.
Les gens qui vous sollicitent, c'est
pour avoir une opinion, c'est pour avoir
une idée, c'est pour avoir une réponse.
Je suis pas allé solliciter les uns ou
les autres, je n'ai rien à vendre. Donc
quand je vais voir des gens, c'est qui
sollicitent mon avis. Je connais Bernard
a été l'un de ceux qui m'ont sollicité à
l'époque où j'avais des fonctions chez
DF que je suis allé rencontrer à
l'époque pour lui dire mes convictions
et partager avec lui quelques
réflexions.
Donc on est parti de ce constat qui
était pas un constat,
je dirais spontané qui a été voulu
préparer, fabriqué depuis 1946
à l'époque de de la fin de la guerre et
de la création d'électricité de France
dans la perspective de donner au pays.
Les trois défis majeurs qui avaient été
engagés à l'époque, c'était
l'indépendance énergétique en matière
d'électricité. On était très loin.
La France ne disposait ni de pétrole,
ni de gaz et de très peu de charbon par
rapport à ses voisins. Compar à France,
à l'Allemagne ou à la Pologne par
exemple, on avait des ressources
charbonnières qui étaient très faibles
par rapport à cela.
Donc la préoccupation des du
gouvernement de l'époque qui était
d'ailleurs un gouvernement gauliste et
communiste, c'est de dire "Oh là là, la
France est dans un état préoccupant, il
faut lui donner une vision, il faut lui
donner une force." Donc dans le domaine
de l'énergie dont nous considérons
disait-il qu'il est essentiel pour la
compétitivité économique industrielle,
il faut que la France une ambition, une
volonté, une vision.
Ça a été le départ.
Le choix qui a été fait, c'était
l'hydraulique. Ils ont dopé la
production hydraulique française
et l'option nucléaire qui à l'époque
était risqué puisqu'on avait pas la
compétence et la séance. La bombe aussi,
pardon,
il fallait un peu de plutonium.
Non, mais ça c'est autre chose. Je parle
là de l'électricité et donc parce
qu'après tout, il y a des pays qui
disposent de la bombe et qui n'ont pas
d'électricité nucléaire ou très peu
britannique par exemple. Mais
ils ont des copains outreatlantiques.
Pardon ?
Ils ont des copains outreatlantiques.
Non mais la France n'avait rien.
Enfin rien dans ce domaine.
Donc on est allé chercher aux États-Unis
la compétence dont nous avions besoin
c'était Westing House qui nous a on est
allé chercher Westing House d'abord on a
hésité entre le graphit de gaz comme
tout le monde et l'eau lourde l'eau
légère. Enfin je veux pas revenir sur
l'histoire industrielle du pays mais on
a eu des hésitations. Pas été immédiat.
On a on a hésité, pris des options. La
générale d'électricité qui était un
grand acteur industriel de l'époque
choisissait plutôt le lourd EDF. Euh
je peux vous couper ?
Oui.
De tout le spectre que vous avez
rencontré, lesquels étaient les moins
trépanés pour pouvoir faire survivre la
France ?
C'est des individus, c'est pas des c'est
pas des c'est pas des partis politiques.
Il y a des individus lucides et qui qui
cherchent à éclairer leur jugement sur
la base de raisonnement auquel ils
adhèrent ou pas. Euh donc il y a eu chez
les communistes, prenons cet exemple là,
chez les Républicains autrefois RPR,
euh des gens qui au fond ont adhéré à
cette idée, à cette conviction. Au
rassemblement, bah ils m'ont posé la
question, j'ai dit ce que je pensais.
Après, ils ont fait leur le leur
homework, si je puis dire. Donc c'est
c'est pas c'est pas une trajectoire
politiquement tracée. Euh les
socialistes quand vous regarder la
campagne de Miteran en 1981 au moins des
élections de 81, il est parti sur un
constat antinucléaire. il a il a fait
une campagne antinucléaire et puis sous
ces deux septen il a construit les deux
tiers du parc nucléaire existant parce
qu'il a intégré l'intérêt du pays
des socialistes enfin aurait pu tel donc
vous voyez bien que ça ça ne ça ne au
fond les partis politiques sont des
éléments de référence certes qui ont des
convictions, qui ont des programmes mais
que la réalité industrielle peut
transcender tel ou tel programme. parti
politique. Et donc le nucléaire a fait
partie de la grande aventure
industrielle française qui de Gaulle
jusqu'à
Chiak n'a pas été remise en cause sauf
au moins de la cohabitation Josmin
parané hein première entorse et l'arrêt
de Super Phenix première entorse à à je
dirais l'outil nucléaire français à
cette trajectoire qui était au fond
linéaire et qui a et qui a transcendé
les les courants politiques
et puis euh
donc la France a investi massivement
dans ces domaines. Je essayer de faire
un calcul rapidement là récemment au
fond, je pense que l'outil
énergétique
électrique français enfit les
infrastructures énergétiques dans le
domaine électrique de production, de
transport, de distribution, c'est
compris entre 1000 et 1500 milliards
d'euros qui a été investi dans ce
domaine
de de 1500 milliards d'euros de l'époque
non non d'aujourd'hui. d'aujourd'hui
qui qui au fond représente
tout l'investissement qu'a fait le la
France qu'on fait les Français pour se
doter d'un outil qui leur donnait à la
fois l'indépendance énergétique, la
compétitivité du territoire.
Ça c'était un une exigence communiste de
l'époque. Le 3è défi c'était un contrat
de service public parce que il y a eu
ça. On était fier d'être une entreprise
de service public. un contrat de service
public, c'est-à-dire le même prix pour
tout le monde, quel que soit son site
son lieu de résidence sur le territoire
euh avec la même qualité de service et
euh la couverture des besoins de la même
manière. Et ce ce contrat de ti public,
ne l'oublions pas puisqueon on est en
train de enfin de le jeter aux orties.
Il a fait une cohésion,
il a fait la fierté de la France.
C'était la référence de la France dans
le monde contre séance public de
l'électricité en France.
Trois défis. l'ancien 46 qui paraissait
inatteignable et qui ont été remportés.
4e auquel on s'était pas vraiment
préparé parce que on l'a fait par
hasard, ça pas été une volonté, c'était
les émissions de gaz effet de serre
parce qu'à l'époque ça n'existait pas.
C'était pas une préoccupation et
maintenant que c'est devenu une
préoccupation, ah le miracle c'est qu'au
fond on est le pays le plus vertueux en
matière d'émission de gaz effet de serre
dans l'univers énergétique
de l'électricité.
Donc on avait coché toutes les cases, ce
qui était vrai il y a 20 ans, on avait
coché toutes les cases. Il fallait donc
casser ça. Et là intervient
effectivement le bilon et les énergies
renouvelables. Il faut imposer les on
avait pas besoin.
Ce sont des gies non pilotables, non
compétitives en terme de prix de
revenir, pas
national en matière de de d'outils
puisque tout est importé
notamment d'Asie et
et qui renchérissent considérablement.
Alors et comme on ne sait pas stocker
l'énergie électrique hein, ça c'est
aussi le débat qu'on peut qu'on peut
nourrir mais on ne sait pas le faire.
les les stockage coûte extrêmement cher
et on n' pas trouvé une manière de
stocker l'énergie autre que la le seule
manière rationnelle efficace de
stockage, c'est l'hydro, c'est-à-dire
les barrages.
D'où le fait qu'il fallait mettre en PF
les barrages comme ça au moins ça
détruisait
en plus
cet atout là. Donc
c'est quand même un plan structuré pour
nous à genou.
Oui. Oui. Mais revenons à l'essentiel.
l'essentiel, c'est qu'on a investi 1500
milliards d'euros, qu'on avait un outil
absolument compétitif qui avait donné à
la France d'un tout considérable en
matière de compétitivité industrielle et
donc d'attractivité du territoire en
matière d'énergie, d'où le fait que tous
les électrintensifs étaient installés en
France et pas ailleurs.
Et ça
a été peu à peu d enfin
mis en pièce
par un
des réglementations européennes
désintégration de l'outil, c'est-à-dire
au fond les réseaux doivent être séparés
de l'outil de production et donc ne doit
pas avoir accès à ses propres clients et
cetera. de la le mythe de euh la de la
concurrence la la concurrence et le
monur des peuples, hein. C'est bien
c'est bien entendu les Allemands ont
inventé ça comme ils avaient inventé que
le travail la liberté par le travail.
Donc donc
on connait le principe.
Ouais. Donc
puisque la concurrence fait le bonheur
des peuples, il peut pas y avoir de
bonheur s'il y a pas de concurrence.
Donc
ce monopole qui est EDF
rend les Français malheureux.
On va créer la concurrence, ça va les
rendre heureux. La concurrence c'était
quoi ? On oblige DF à vendre 25 % de ses
capacités électronuclairire à ses
propres concurrent qui n'existait pas.
Donc des traders bon à un prix qui était
très inface coup de revient.
Ça deux vertus. un, on enrichissait
considérablement
les traders en question puisqu'on leur
vendait l'énergie moins chère qu'on
avait qu'on a produit pour qu'il la
vendre au clients de DF.
Je sens quand même un gros tacle sur les
Allemands quand même là.
Mais j'ai pas dit le contraire, je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure, les Allemands
avaient intérêt à détruire DF. Ils l'ont
fait avec la complicité des autorités
françaises. C'est ça que je regrette.
Et on a les noms des autorités
françaises parce que
bien sûr de puisque vous vendez en
dessous de votre coup de revient, vous
êtes obligé d'augmenter votre prix de
vente pour être à l'équilibre. Donc plus
vous augmentez le prix de vente, plus ça
accroit
le profit des traders qui vous achètent
votre énergie à Bakou.
et on a enrichi odieusement des gens qui
ne produisaient rien, qui vendaient
l'énergie de DF au client de DF avec en
plus un argument formidable. On vend de
l'énergie verte alors que c'était
l'énergie de DF qu'on leur vendait.
Bon, j'ai dit tout ça. Tout ça, je l'ai
dit, je l'ai même écrit.
Et donc les politiques, ils ont pris les
mesures en question pour aller attraper
tous ces gens qui sont payés dans
Pas du tout, pas du tout, pas du tout.
Ils ont vendu euh la plupart d'entre
eux, tous ces traders ont vendu à total
à des prix absolument astronomiques
euh leurs leurs actifs. Euh moi je vais
te souvenir du direct énergie, je les
connaissais bien.
Ils ont démarré à partir de zéro. Je les
ai même aidé à survivre pour éviter que
NG ne ramasse mon et euh ils se sont
vendus à total
euh 2 milliards900 millions d'euros il y
a une dizaine d'années et un des deux
fondateurs m'appelle un jour en me
disant vous savez
je veux dire Henry je suis je suis quand
même c'est un passement au cœur je
quitte mon bureau parce que je dis ouais
enfin un passement au cœur compensé par
1 500 million
bon c'est vrai que c'est dramatique mais
au fond Bon, ça se soigne quoi. Bon, il
a quand même touché un M5 pour 50 % des
actions qu'il avait simplement. Bon,
pour rien, pour avoir acheté l'énergie
DF et le vendre au client de DF.
Or, il a un peu de frottement, c'est
tout. Donc
quand même quand vous voyez ça et puis
on nous dit aujourd'hui, non mais il
faut augmenter les renouvelables,
il faut aller vers de plus en plus
d'électricité. promouvoir l'électricité
donc augmenter la production
renouvelable.
Pourquoi on consomme aujourd'hui 10 %
d'électricité de moins qu'il y a 10 ans
en France ?
À cause de la récession,
à cause de la désindustrialisation
essentiellement.
Donc non seulement on a pas besoin mais
on a encore moins besoin qu'hier.
Pourquoi c'est poussé tout ça ? Donc je
dis au fond si vous voulez c'est là où
vous avez de quoi enfin quand je vois
que les français la média des Français
vit avec 2500 € par mois et que les gens
sont je au limite de la rupture
pourquoi est-ce qu'on leur vend
l'énergie électrique devrait être moins
cher qu' a 10 ans puisque le parc de
production étant le même il était un peu
plus amorti et donc on aurait pu baisser
la facture d'à peu près entre 10 20 25
Elle a été multiplié par 2 et demi
au profit de qui ?
Raison de quoi ?
Et c'est là où ça me fait quand même
réagir
donc
ça sent quoi la corruption ? Ça sent le
renflouement ça sent il tire la
couverture pour cacher les finances de
l'État. Il faut finance de l'État. Au
contraire, vous avez dans le budget de
l'État 50 milliards consacrés chaque
année à la transition écologique. C'est
ça la transition écologique. On
subventionne des énergies inutiles.
Attendez, je Pourquoi voulez-vous
développer les éléments offshore qui
vont vous coûter entre 250 300 € le mWh
?
Qui sont de plus en plus loin des côtes
? parce que les gens n'en veulent plus.
Donc maintenant vous faites 30 40 km
plus vous éloignez des côtes, plus il
faut que ça soit flotant, plus c'est
cher.
Et à quoi ça sert puisqu'on en a pas
besoin.
C'est c'est là où le bon sens s'éloigne
de chez nous, hein. Et on ne le dit pas
aux gens.
On continue à alimenter le peuple comme
un des mortels
d'une désinformation à savoir que on a
besoin de plus en plus d'énergie
électrique. Non, on en a on en consomme
moins.
Donc si on veut développer les les
l'électricité, il faut la rendre
compatible avec les enjeux ou la
compétitivité industrielle. Il faut le
vendre moins cher.
Bernard,
en fait euh tout cela
Merci Henri
tout cela euh révèle
une grande défaillance
une grande défaillance de la part
grande corruption.
J'ai pas dit ça. J'ai dit une grande
défaillance
de la part de l'appareil de l'État, de
la gouvernance et des institutions
chargées
de veiller à ce que la France dispose
d'énergie à un prix qui soit le plus bas
possible pour les ménages et pour les
entreprises. Or, de ce côté-là, depuis
plus de 10 ans, tout le monde a
défailli. Alors, d'abord, il y a eu une
défaillance du côté de l'État. La le
ministère de l'environnement qui à
partir de 2007
a été en charge de l'énergie, ce qui
était une volonté de Nicolas Hullot à
laquelle a cédé Nicolas Sarkozy,
a une vision de l'énergie et en
particulier de l'énergie nucléaire qui
est une vision négative. L'énergie
s'apolue et le nucléaire c'est
dangereux.
Et et et c'est l'horreur. Il
a réchauffement climatique pour les
refroidir, ça va être compliqué.
Et alors tous les moyens sont bons pour
bâcher le nucléaire. Ça c'est pas un
argument, on pourrait aller dans le
détail.
Donc défaillance des services du
ministère,
défaillance d'une institution qui
s'appelle l'ADEM, l'Agence
développement, l'environnement, je ne
sais quoi, qui a un budget de 4
milliards et qui est une une agence
militante qui n'a fait que reproduire
les scénarios imaginé par une
association antinucléaire et des
croisances
militante qui s'appelle Négawat,
laquelle est subventionnée d'ailleurs
par le par l'État et par le ministère de
l'environnement. Donc on on se renvoie
l'ascenseur l'ADEM aant même
vous dites que c'est des militants à
l'an même parce qu'ils sont militants
c'est factuel.
Allant même pour l'ADEM a expliqué que
le nucléaire était une énergie carbonée.
Alors, ils ont expliquer après que
c'était une erreur d'impression mais
enfin ils avaient distribué les tractes
pour aller dans ce domaine. défaillance
également d'une autorité prétendument
indépendante, haut autorité qui
s'appelle la Creux, Commission de
régulation de l'énergie qui au lieu de
de remplir sa mission légale qui est de
protéger le consommateur final n'a fait
que protéger les promoteurs d'énergie
renouvelable et les revendeurs
alternatifs. D'ailleurs ces traders qui
ont fait des fortunes colossales sur le
dos des DF, des consommateurs et de
l'État parce que c'est ça qui pens des
gens qui vont terminer en prison ?
Non, parce que tout cela malheureusement
n'est pas euh illégal et ceux qui ont
manipulé ont fait les choses avec une
certaine
habileté. Donc défaillance en chaînne
qui relève relève de l'État qui dont les
services n'ont pas écouté les
avertissements. Il y a eu de multiples
rapports qui ont été produits par les au
commissaire à l'énergie atomique en
particul mais pas que lui. Le rapport
colléon d'Iscata d'Escata en 2018 où
explique on expliquait qu'il fallait
vite reconstruire relancer la filière
nucléaire. On en a rien fait. En 2019 a
été arrêté le projet Astrid,
c'est-à-dire ce que l'État avait décidé
par la loi de 2006
adopté à l'unanimité pour sauver les
savoir-fa que la France avait su
constituer dans la 4e génération
nucléaire, c'est-à-dire celle qui
consomme les déchets pour produire de
l'énergie. La France aurait des des
siècles et des siècles de réserve de
combustible avec cette filière. Nous
avions 20 ans d'avance, tout avait été
perdu. Et et dans la loi de 2006, il a
été décidé d'essayer de sauver ce que
l'on savait avec un projet qui s'appelle
réacteur expérimental Astrid. En 2019,
il est arrêté alors qu'il était qui ?
Et bien en 2019, c'est le président
Macron qui arrête le réacteur Astrid. En
2020, on arrête les deux réacteurs de
Fessenheim. Le Parlement entre-temps a
légiféré sur les les utopies qui
consistaient à euh réduire la part du
nucléaire dans le parc euh dans le mix
dans le mix électrique. Et le et le
Parlement n'a n'a jamais disposé avec
ces lois des études d'impact notamment
sur les conséquences sur le réseau, sur
la remise en cause de tout le système
qui ne pouvait pas fonctionner en raison
de l'intermittence. Jamais le Parlement
n'a disposé de ces études d'impact.
Pourtant, celles-ci sont obligatoires
depuis le organique de 2009. Donc, il
n'y a pas eu il y a eu toute une série
de de dysfonctionnements qui ont ont
conduit à la situation actuelle. Alors,
vous allez me dire qui sont les
responsables ?
Tout ça est dilué et puis finalement
c'est une responsabilité politique. Tout
ça remonte à l'accord de 2012 entre
François Hollande et Récoleville les
verts. On se souvient du débat au cours
de l'élection
de la campagne d'élection présidentielle
de 2012 où d'un côté
Sarkozy défend le nucléaire et de
l'autre côté on entend encore la phrase
de François Hollande avec moi je
fermerai la centrale de Fessenheim et je
réduirai à 50 % la part du nucléaire
dans l'Union français. C'était un
argument de campagne mais c'était en
même temps une trahison d'une grande
réussite euh française. Après, il y a eu
des pirouettes politiques pour expliquer
non, c'est pas moi, c'est ceci, ce
prestation du ministre d'État, de
l'environnement et de l'énergie,
monsieur Hullot, qui devant la
commission d'enquête
reconnaît que ben ma fois il a pas eu
vent d'un rapport qu'il avait lui-même
commandé qui lui a été remis en 2018 qui
c'était le rapport, je viens de parler,
d'Escata Colébillon qui recommandait
vite de reconstruire des de relancer la
construction de
de réacteur nucléaire. Donc il y a une
défaillance politique. Il y avait eu en
avant une trahison politique. Celle-ci
remonte Henry Progliot lui a fait
allusion tout à l'heure à madame Voinet.
Madame Voinet est ministre de
l'environnement de monsieur Jospin.
Jospin qui a pourtant porté un coup de
poignard à la filière et la l'industrie
et la recherche nucléaire française en
en ordonnant la fermeture
de Supernix
de de Super Phenniix. Et bien malgré
tout, il dit à sa ministre de
l'environnement d'aller défendre le
nucléaire à Bruxelles et elle va faire
le contraire et elle s'en est flatter
sur les réseaux sociaux. C'est une
trahison. C'est de la haute trahison. Et
bien, bien que cela a été reconnu dans
la commission d'enquête parlementaire,
elle n'a pas eu de il y a pas eu de
suite judiciire. Je je trouve que c'est
extrêmement dommageable. Aujourd'hui,
madame Voinet est à nouveau
parlementaire. Elle a même été nommée
dans une instance de surveillance de la
transparence sur le nucléaire.
véritablement euh les les trahisons,
j'emploie ce mot, euh peuvent être Oui,
je je pense que c'est une c'est même une
haute trahison. Peuvent être répété les
les les fautes les plus graves à
l'intérieur à l'endroit des intérêts
industriels et économiques les plus
importants du pays peuvent être
perpétrés. Ce sont des fautes
politiques. Donc ma fois et bien on va
passer Henri Dominique Voinet. On l' on
l'a vu cette vidéo où elle se targuait
d'avoir fait l'inverse.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait là ?
Rien.
Bernard, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? E bien,
je pense que la commission d'enquête euh
Chelen Berger euh Armand euh qui avait
connaissance de cette haute trahison
aurait dû euh euh demander euh euh
transmettre euh à la justice, en
l'occurrence, quand elle était ministre,
ça aurait relevé de la corruptice de la
République
euh
son cas, ça n'a pas été fait. Et ben,
elle recommence et elle continue.
Pourquoi elle continue ?
Parce que c'est une militante
antinucléaire. et c'est c'est son c'est
son idéal, c'est c'est sa c'est son
obsession. Entre-temps, elle a quand
même eu l'avantage après avoir été
ministre et avoir porté autant de tort
d'être nommé inspecteur général de
l'action sociale. Alors, je me rappelle
plus en quelle année ça devait être.
Hollande
je sais pas qui l'a nommé. En tout cas,
elle a été nommée et euh bon euh son
passage dans ses responsabilités n'a pas
laissé euh une image particulement
brillante.
On a ti attention Henri. D'après EDF en
France, la consommation électrique
d'électricité a triplé entre 73 et 2010
avant de se stabiliser jusqu'à
aujourd'hui.
C'est pas décruissé.
Elle a baissé combien pour 10 de l'ordre
de 10 %.
Euh question. et les deux EPR2 et les
EPR2 annoncés par Macron.
Ça ça on est où les EPR2 ?
Bon euh, il faudrait demander à des à
des experts. Le PR2, le PR2 c'est un
c'est un
non c'est un projet
issu des déconvenus de le PR destiné à
corriger des erreurs
je inhérentes à la
à la conception de PR qui comme vous le
savez
comme les les gens du le savent était un
projet
Areva
Simons,
projet franco-allemand qui devait porter
l'avenir du nucléaire européen.
forcé de constater que d'une part cet
engin le PR a été conçu en respectant
les règles de sécurité des deux
autorités de sûreté allemande et
française et que l'accumulation je
dirais des des contraintes a fait que
c'est devenu
c'est un enginur absolument
inconstructible enfin
euh au point que toute PR qui a été
construit a
13 à 15 ans de retard, c'est pas plus
cher
et des dépassements de coût qui comm qui
se chiffre 1 milliard d'années par
1 milliard par année de retard,
c'est-à-dire 13 à 15 milliards de
surcoup sur un budget initial de 3
milliards imaginés par par rava. Donc au
fond, c'est ce sont des
des réacteurs qui n'ont aucune
je dirais capacité
à fabriquer de l'énergie à un prix
acceptable parce que l'électricité c'est
quand même une commodité. On peut pas
vendre d'électricité
Hermes contre Tati quoi quand on branche
son son faire passer ou qu'on qu'on
branche on charge son téléphone
c'est une commodité donc il faut qu'elle
soit accessible à tout le monde et et il
y a pas une énergie électrique qui soit
préférable à une autre sauf à travers
son coudre et donc il fallait que le
nucléaire soit compétitif ce que n'est
pas le père
for de ce constat
après la dérive de de d'Okigyoto en
Finlande Flamville et même des EPR
chinois de Taïan, il a
j'avais personnellement présidé la
décision en commun avec Areva en
l'occurrence
le président d'Arieva de l'époque Lucel
de
travailler sur un EPR simplifié
évitant tous les surcouts et les et les
pè initial.
J'ai quitté la maison, c'est devenu le
PR2. On a pris beaucoup de temps, on a
pris 10 ans de retard avant de
travailler vraiment sur le sujet puisque
entre-temps la doctrine étatique était
de de s'écarter du nucléaire.
Bon alors aujourd'hui depuis un an ou un
an et demi, on est revenu au nucléaire
et on annonce la construction des PR2
dont le design n'est pas encore arrêté.
Donc euh j'ai du mal euh à pororter un
jugement sur le PR2. Moi, j'aurais
imaginé que le PR2 serait une puissance
qui soit réduite à 1000 MW, ce qui est
le besoin du marché. On est resté sur
les 1700 MW pour ne pas remettre en
cause tout le tout le schéma de le PR.
Mais euh voilà, vous donner je je bon,
il faudrait que je consulte
les anciens collaborateurs de DF pour
être plus précis sur l'état de au moins
de de
capacité qu' DF à construire les EPR2.
En tout cas, pour l'instant
euh c'est encore un projet.
On va allergir un peu le focus. La Chine
qui construit directeur par an.
Euh s'il y a déjà des plots de béton
coulé, ça avance fort. Une capacité,
ils se construisent. Ou
ou ils se construisent. Nous, nous on
fait du blabla. C'est ça. Par rapport à
tout ça,
Bah il y avait à l'époque, enfin pour
remettre les choses en perspective,
j'ai été en situation à l'époque de DF
entre 2009 et 2014, enfin 2014 de
constater que le PR était une grande
difficulté, qu'il fallait donc aller
vers autre chose. Donc on avait passé un
accord avec les Chinois euh
qui consistait à mettre au point un
nouveau réacteur de 1000 MW. consid
comme d'habitude
le marché était autour de ces de ces
capacités là et euh lors de la visite du
président chinois en visite d'état en
France en 2011 à l'époque Ring Tao
président de la République populaire de
Chine
et au dîner d'État l'Élysée qui s'est
mis à cette époque là alors à l'occasion
de son déplacement je me souviens de ces
mots qui figurent dans le discours qu'il
a prononcé qui a été remis à chacun des
des participants. Je me réjouis du
renforcement de la coopération
euh dans le nucléaire civil entre la
Chine et la France et
du lancement d'un nouveau secteur de
moyenne puissance
en commun entre nos deux nations
à destination du marché chinois et
international.
C'està-dire qu'au fond, on avait
remporté
en tout cas euh l'estime des Chinois que
nous avions déjà depuis 30 ans puisque
le DF avait construit les premiers
acteurs chinois et les Chinois avaient
confié à ce à ce je dirais ce consortium
franco-chinois l' création du nouveau
réacteur qui allait équiper la
République pour de Chine.
J'ai quitté cette maison en fin 2014.
Euh bon, le gouvernement français de
l'époque a tourné le dos nucléaire.
Nous avons
multiplié, je dirais les contresens avec
nos partenaires chinois au point que les
Chinois ont finalement
Bon, j'ai été d'abord critiqué pour on a
parlé du contrat
caché de progli chinois comme si j'étais
traître
à la France et des revues de l'époque
des journaux grand tirages
parler du scandale et cetera. Les
Chinais ont été très très meurtris par
cette campagne de presse.
Ce qui fait qu'à la fin, moi j'ai eu
droit à une enquête de la DGSE, une
enquête de l'inspection des finances qui
s'est révélé évidemment
tellement négatif pour l'État qu'elle a
été classifiée sur CR défense pour
éviter qu'elle soit mise entre les mains
des mêmes journaux qui m'avaient
insulté.
Mais ça c'est de vieux souvenirs. Les
ont été très choqués par ce climat, ont
décidé de rompre toute relation et ils
ont créé
le roi long, c'est-à-dire le réacteur de
1000 MW destiné au marché chinois qui
équipe les fameux directeurs chaque
année
et qui sont le réacteur de base de la
nouvelle plateforme chinoise. C'est un
réacteur de type 1000 mag français
signisé. Alors nous on avait francisé le
recteur de Westing House. Ils ont repris
nos nos nos démarches et puis ils ont
modernisé, signisé leur électeur. Ils
ont créé un nouveau récteur qui est
celui qui équipe le parc nucléaire
chinois. Aujourd'hui, les directeurs qui
sont chaque année sont des longs
dispar.
Ouais. et nous
n'avons disparu.
Donc le problème en fait c'est que
nous n'avons pas besoin de construire
des réacteurs en France
ni en terme de volume puisqu'on a volume
de consommation baissé ni en terme
de de calendrier puisqu'on peut
prolonger de 20 ans la durée de vie des
réacteurs existants.
On a simplement besoin de construire de
réacteur pour garder le savoir-faire
de construction de réacteur
et puis 20 ans 20 ans c'est demain non ?
Oui c'est demain. Il faut 10 ans pour
construire un réacteur.
Et les besoins en intelligence
artificielle en électricité pour
l'intelligence artificielle
estce que est-ce qu'ils ont été mesurés
? Est-ce qu'on a certitude qui vont être
en France ? Est-ce que
et notre dépendance de gaz ? C'est pour
ça qu'il faut nous électrifier. Notre
dépendance au pétrole, ça c'est autre
chose. Le pétrole ne peut pas être
remplacé par électricité très
facilement. On a vu avec l'automobile
que
la réalité était loin des fantaismes.
Dépenses liées au gaz. Oui. Enfin, il y
a une réglementation thermique toujours
en place dite RT 2012 qui prévoit que
seul le gaz doit être utilisé pour les
nouveaux lâchements depuis 2012.
Pas été rectifié.
Donc
oui, on peut spéculer mais pour
l'instant les besoins d'électricité ne
sont pas au rendez-vous
et donc on peut prolonger la durée de
vie des recteurs existant qui permet de
de de je dirais bénéficier
de leur amortissement et donc
50 € le m
Ouais 55 y compris les provisions donc
c'est de entre 50 et 60 imbattable
si on con nouveau réacteur
Ça va faire bondir la facture
oui 200 enfin ça double quand même. Donc
avant de construire nouveau réacteur
encore faut-il avoir la conscience du
fait que on en a besoin. Donc ma
conviction c'était qu'il fallait quand
même que l'industrie française parce
qu'il y a une différence entre les
besoins de la France et de l'industrie
française. L'industrie française a pour
ambition d'être mondial de pas être
simplement hexagonal. Donc il fallait
pour l'industrie française vendre des
réacteurs à l'international.
Donc le partenari avec les Chinois
permettait justement de faire en sorte
que notre industrie nucléaire travaille
sur des réacteurs dans le développement
international du nucléaire.
C'était ça le but.
Bernard.
Bien sûr que il est infiniment
regrettable que des décisions
politiques, des nomination hasardeuse
est conduit à cette déconvenu. Nous
avions besoin évidemment de continuer la
grande aventure dans ce partenariat
international et en particulier avec la
Chine. Néanmoins, nous aurons quand même
nous avons besoin de garder notre
savoir-faire. Nous aurons besoin de
construire plus tard parce que tôt ou
tard malgré tout même si on les prolonge
à 60 peut-être à 80 ans, ces réacteurs
arriveront en fin de vie et le temps
passe très vite. Donc il faut se
préparer, il faut préparer la suite et
et il ne faut pas admettre que l'on
achètera
des réacteurs étrangers. Il ne peut pas
même si peut pas exclure hein cette
cette cet aboutissement. Donc
personnellement, je pense que le
sauvetage industriel de notre pays, le
sauvetage économique de la France fait
que nous devons à tout prix euh euh
retrouver euh le le moyen euh de renouer
avec les savoir-faires, la construction.
On a un parc, on l'a maintenu, on l'a
modernisé, on a fait le grand carénage,
tout ça montre qu'il y a quand même du
monde qui connaît tout ça et qui
travaille et qui maîtrise et il faut
relancer. et et et c'est absolument
indispensable. On aura besoin de plus
d'électricité, pas tout de suite parce
que pour le moment une production qui
est largement
excédentaire et que nous exportons non
pas comme on le dit de manière
extrêmement glorieuse mais à ville prix
à bas prix et de surcroix. Nous mettons
en difficulté notre parc nucléaire en en
se voyant imposer la modulation,
c'estàdire la réduction production
d'électricité par notre parc pour
laisser passer l'électricité d'origine
éolienne et photovoltaïque. C'est un non
sens. Il faut absolument que cette
situation soit dénoncée parce que
d'abord c'est pas fait pour ça. Le parc
français certes il est modulable mais on
peut pas faire n'importe quoi. Et puis
c'est un gros gâchi. Que paye qui ? et
bien les consommateurs parce que
les les la rentabilité des réacteurs
diminue si on les fait pas tourner un
maximum un maximum de temps. Et dans le
même temps Et dans le même temps alors
qu'on indemnis pas le nucléaire quand il
réduit sa production et bien quand les
l'éolien et le solaire ne produisent pas
ou que ils vendent à un prix qui leur
qui est en dessous des prix qui ont été
convenus, et bien l'État, c'est-à-dire
le contribuable mais aussi le
consommateur passe à la caisse pour que
cette activité finalement ne soit jamais
déficitaire. Donc si vous voulez les
renouvelables, c'est à tous les coups on
gagne. Donc évidemment il y a de gros
lobby et évidemment il y a une énorme
pression sur le pouvoir politique pour
qu'on publie la PPE3 afin qu'il puisse
lancer des appels d'offre notamment pour
de l'éolien flottant en mer où le prix
euh du mégawat est deux à trois fois le
prix même très élevé et je pense qu'il
sera moins élevé de de de l'électricité
produite par le nouveau nucléaire. Donc
on marche sur la tête et surtout on
trahit les intérêts français.
C'est quoi c'est quoi leurs arguments ?
Parce qu'ils doivent avoir quand même
des arguments ces gens-là pour pouvoir
remporter.
Alors leurs arguments, c'est de dire on
a besoin d'électricité. C'est faux
puisque comme cela vient d'être dit euh
on on on exp on exporte une partie
importante de notre surproduction et
encore on pourrait produire plus si on
ne on ne modulait pas le nucléaire. Donc
cet argument ne tient absolument pas.
Donc l'argument de dire on a besoin
d'électricité, c'est faux. Dire on en
aura besoin plus tard. Oui, mais comme
on a déjà une grosse marge et que la
consommation à baisser, on peut voir
venir. On a le temps euh de développer.
C'est
des intérêts là-dedans.
Bah c'est des intérêts industriels,
c'est des intérêts commerciaux, c'est
des intérêts spéculatifs, c'est
l'intérêt des vendeurs de gaz. Parce que
quand on fait prospérer à l'étranger,
c'est-à-dire en en Allemagne ou en
Espagne ou ailleurs, les les l'éoliens
et le solaire, ça veut dire qu'à côté,
ils ont des centrales à gaz. Donc c'est
de là que madame VERleyen considère
qu'il faut acheter beaucoup de gaz. Mais
tout ça c'est au c'est au détriment des
intérêts français. Et alors, je voudrais
juste terminer en disant que on veut
développer euh énormément les
interconnexions. Mais pour à quoi vont
servir ces interconnexions ? à nous
faire envahir par une électricité
intermittente qui obligera à à moduler
notre nucléaire, c'est n'importe quoi.
On se tire des balles dans le pied.
Bon,
on a fait le constat, on se tire des
balles dans le pied, les gens
connaissent pas le sujet, il y a des
gros intérêts.
Le français landa làdedans, il peut
aller s'informer où ? Et bien si je
pense que ce qu'a fait la creux qui
vient d'émettre une lettre d'information
qui est un véritable tracte publicitaire
mensongère en faveur de l'éolien et du
solaire mériterait d'être évalué et
probablement d'engager des poursuites.
PNC France qui est l'association que je
préside
c'est financé comment ?
Ah c'est uniquement les cotisations des
adhérents et leurs dons uniquement.
Il y a combien de personnes ? Oh bon,
nous sommes depuis qu'on s'est créé, on
doit être à peu près 700.
Le profil, c'est quoi ? C'est des petits
retraités ? C'est quoi ?
C'est ce sont des citoyens de toute
origine. Il y a beaucoup d'ingénieurs,
il y a beaucoup de gens euh qui viennent
des DF, qui viennent euh du CEA, euh des
ingénieurs dans d'autres domaines et
puis il y a des citoyens normaux.
Moi, je suis médecin, voyez, je suis pas
un ingénieur et je ne vais pas
m'aventurer sur les questions
techniques, mais je pense que l'intérêt
du pays mérite que l'on on se dévoue
pour cela totalement bénévolement.
Henry, où est-ce que le citoyen Londa
peut s'informer ?
Non, mais la difficulté est tend enfin
la difficulté claire enfin c'est que
euh
il y a il y a un outil de désinformation
considérable qui a été réalisé en fait
avec
quoi ? On a des fact checkers quand
même.
Pardon ?
On a des facts checkers. Hm.
Pourquoi ? euh
au-delà de des options politiques ou
politiciennes de certains on a parlé des
ver, il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup
maintenant euh au cours des années de
d'intérêts majeurs qui se sont investis
là-dedans,
notamment à travers les fonds
d'investissement,
c'està-dire que vous avait
des dizaines de milliards qui ont été
consacrés par les fondis
d'infrastructure ou d'investissement
qui vendent à leurs adhérents.
Ce sont des gens qui collectent des
fonds qui ne leur appartiennent pas et
qui investissent dans ces actifs réputés
réputés je dirais
sérieux et et et
je dirais offrant des rendements
intéressants à long terme.
tous quasiment tous les fonds
d'investissement y compris ceux des
banques,
se sont livrés à des investissement dans
ce domaine. Euh
évidemment les pétroliers, le pétrolier
français en particulier.
Ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
les enjeux en terme de d'actifs investi
sont considérables et encore une fois la
rentabilité vient de quoi ? des
subventions accordées par l'État, donc
par le contribuable.
Et ça
ça crée, je dirait un outil de
propagande extraordinairement puissant.
Et quand vous dites des choses qui au
fond ne vont pas dans l'intérêt de ces
gens-là,
vous vous
suscitez des réaction extrêmement
violente. Donc aujourd'hui, faire
entendre une voix raisonnable, enfin qui
est au fond celle du intérêts public ou
d'intérêt commun est extrêmement
difficile.
Vous avez ici et là des initiatives
imaginées ou conduites par des gens qui
se considèrent comme responsable qui
disent des choses qui qu'il est bon de
ne pas dire mais mais qui n'ont pas
d'intérêt particulier à défendre et donc
qui de ce fait euh ne sont pas
bcables, n'ont pas l'audience de ces de
ces de ces grands investisseurs quoi.
Question intersè difficile.
Question internet. Que pensez-vous de
l'idée d'utiliser le minage de Bitcom
pour valoriser le surplu électrique du
nucléaire ?
Ce qui permettrait de générer des
revenus en période de sous-consommation
à réinjecter dans la filière.
Non mais
aujourd'hui le nucléaire est obligé de
se enfin vous avez une priorité d'accè
au réseau donné au renouvelable. quand
le renouvelable
intervient, c'est-à-dire quand il fait
du soleil ou quand il fait du vent, ce
qui est évidemment non anticipable, non
pilotable, alors il faut que le
nucléaire se retire pour laisser la la
priorité d'accès au réseau renouvelable.
Le nucléaire n'est pas fait pour ça. Le
nucléaire c'est une production de masse,
c'est une production stable, c'est un
haut fourneau. Et donc le nucléaire en
principe fabrique une base.
Le fait de le rendre de l'obliger à se
rendre flexible
impose des modifications considérables à
apporter au réacteur central qui à la
fois coûte très cher
avec conséquence en matière de prix de
revient et donc de prix de vente et qui
vulnérabilise la sécurité des centrales.
Donc c'est à tout coup des inconvénients
dont on mesure le coût direct et
indirect. Mais c'est ainsi.
Plus on rajoute de renouvelable, plus on
rend le problème inextricable.
Donc à moins qu'on décide de fermer les
centrales nucléaires, au quel cas, il
faudra importer du gaz parce que
justement il a on a plus la capacité de
production. Si on réduisait le parc
nucléaire, il faudrait compenser par du
gaz importé pour fabriquer l'énergie
quand il y a pas de vent, qu' a pas de
qu' a pas de de soleil. Donc on est dans
cette situation absurde où on avait un
outil absolument performant qu'on a peu
à peu
étrier ou ou ou abîmer et et et qu'on
veut continuer. Alors on peut si on
devait produire de l'énergie
au moins où on baisse la production
nucléaire. Je comprends la question. Ça
voudrait dire qu'on la vente dans
l'étranger, mais comme il y a du soleil
partout en Europe et du vent partout en
même temps, on la vend à des prix
négatif.
Donc on aurait un coût supplémentaire
qui serait pas du tout compensé par une
pe
faire du minage de Bitcoin avec euh avec
ça au lieu de la vendre à prix négatif.
Mais le prix négatif, il est par
définition qui est qui perçoit le prix
négatif ? Personne.
Question internet.
Peux-tu leur demander pourquoi ils sont
si européistes alors qu'ils font la
longue liste des inepsies des politiques
européennes sur l'énergie depuis tant
d'années ?
Alors bon, moi je j'avoue très très
modestement ne pas être tellement
européiste dans le domaine de l'énergie.
Bon en tout cas
nous ont mis des couteaux dans le dos.
Non non euh non pas du tout par réaction
à la situation telle que je l'ai vécu et
au fond autant je pense que l'Europe a
ses vertus et que la France
doit faire partie de l'Union européenne
mais doit prendre des initiatives pour
renforcer
son influence à Bruxelles parce que
c'est loin d'être le cas. Autant euh
dans le domaine spécifique de l'énergie,
je pense que la France aurait intérêt à
faire comme l'a fait l'Espagne ou le
Portugal en disant "Moi, cette Europe de
l'énergie ne me convient pas. Tant qu'on
change pas les règles, je prends euh une
certaine distance par rapport dans ce
secteur-là
à l'Europe.
L'Espagne et le Portugal l'ont fait, ils
n'ont pas été virés de l'Europe. Je
crois je crois que j'ai répondu, j'ai
dit que l'Europe s'était éloignée de ses
objectifs de départ, c'est-à-dire
l'accès
au à l'énergie, hein, c'était le charbon
et l'acier. Ensuite, ça a été atome. Et
bien l'Europe aujourd'hui ne respecte
même pas, la Commission ne respecte même
pas les termes du traité uratome dans
lequel il est écrit qu'il faut soutenir
et développer le nucléaire civil.
L'Europe doit se réformer profondément
et la France devrait être le moteur de
cette réforme des personnalités.
On a plus le temps, on va se faire
flinguer notre économie là. Mais mais
mais d'un autre côté euh nous n'avons
pas d'autres solutions. On peut pas
décriter du jour au lendemain qu'on sort
qu'on sort de l'Europe.
D'accord. Alors si on peut pas décréter
de sortir de l'Europe, est-ce qu'on peut
un peu mettre l'Allemagne en la parce
que je crois bien qu'il y a de
l'électricité allemande qui transite par
chez nous qu'on pourra leur péter les de
temps en temps. Non. Oui. Mais ça nous
venons de le dire, la France n'a pas
défendu son nucléaire à Bruxelles quand
il le fallait. La France n'a pas défendu
ce nucléaire. Alors maintenant, il faut
mais il faut rattraper. Alors, il y a eu
des choses qui ont été faites. En
particulier, la France a créé l'Union
des États pour le nucléaire et le
patronat euh français et européen s'est
également uni dans le même esprit. Donc
ça bouge, ça ne bouge pas assez vite
parce que l'Europe est une de ces
grandes faiblesses, c'est que c'est une
énorme masse qui qui réagit avec une
inertie gigantesque. Mais le vrai
problème de l'Europe, l'un des vrais
problèmes, c'est le poids des lobbyes.
Le poids des Il y a des dizaines de
milliers de lobbyistes à à Beel et les
Français sont nuls dans le lobbyisme. Je
le dis pour nos entreprises, comme je le
dis pour l'énergie, comme je le dis pour
notre agriculture. On se fait promener.
Nous sommes des amateurs et ces
lobbyistes font financés par l'étranger,
par tel ou tel état, par telle ou telle
filière et et nous on n'est pas à la
hauteur.
D'accord. Mais quand tu dis nous, quand
vous vous dites nous, mais c'est nos nos
élus au Parlement européen.
Oui. Oui. Oui, bien sûr. Mais nos élus
au Parlement européen sont pas assez
présents. Un certain nombre d'entre eux
sont actifs mais pas suffisamment tous.
Et puis ils se disparaissent, ils se
disperent dans différents dans
différents dans différents groupes et
ils se tapent dessus. Mais il faudrait
être beaucoup plus exigeant sur le bilan
du travail de nos parlementaires
européens, beaucoup plus exigeant sur le
bilan de notre représentation française
à Bruxelles et et que on nomme là-bas
quand on nomme un commissaire, on ne
nomme pas l'ami d'un tel mais on nomme
des gens qui sont câblés. Quand je vous
écoute, c'est il y a CA con, c'est pas
bien c'est les écolos. Bon et on peut
faire l'expérience inverse.
Les Allemands qui sont fait financer, du
moins les écolo allemands qui se sont
fait financer par Gasprom ou qui ont été
financés par leur propre état pour nous
mettre des low kics dans les genoux et
nous mettent à terre pour nous mettre en
laisse pour qu'on puisse suivre
l'Allemagne. C'est parce que vous avez
pas été suffisamment bon.
Je pense qu'effectivement la France, je
vous l'ai dit, ne s'est pas défendu, n'a
pas défendu et ne défend pas assez ses
intérêts. Défendre mais il faut attaquer
maintenant.
Ça c'est une ça c'est mais tout ça est
politique. C'est-à-dire qu'il faut que
les formations politiques qui font élire
des parlementaires européens, les
gouvernements qui désignent nos
représentants officiels à Bruxelles leur
mettent des exigences et qu'on voit ce
qu'ils font.
et une feuille et une feuille de route.
OK. Non mais là les exigences elles vont
être mises sur la table. Ça risque de
mal se terminer dans la rue là parce que
l'inflation d'énergie
les licenciements notre industrie qui
qui calanche on se fait racheter par
Pierre Paul Jacques. Il va nous rester
quoi ? Rien. Donc les exigences elles
vont elles vont être vite fait. N'allons
pas si loin. La France reste La France
reste quand même un pays qui a des
atouts considérables. Qu'est-ce qui
reste qui reste ? Ben nous avons quand
même toujours une agriculture, une
industrie, une Oui, nous avons
le mercourd, le prix des introu
bien sûr, mais bien sûr que tout ça les
normes les normes européennes, j'abonde
ce que vous dises dites avec les normes
européennes.
Donc il y a eu des tentatives, il y a eu
notamment une loi, il nous reste
nous avons eu une loi qui vient d'être,
il nous reste quoi d'autre ? Il y a eu
alors l'agriculture, il vient d'y avoir
une loi
quoi d'autre
qui a essayé de protéger quelques
secteurs agricoles. Elle a été annulé
par un certain nombre de ces
dispositions par le Conseil
constitutionnel. C'est tout ça qu'il
faut
Il nous reste quoi d'autre ?
Et il nous reste une industrie. Nous
avons une industrie aéronautique. Nous
avons des industries qui sont encore qui
occupent à peu près plus de 10 % de
notre PIB. C'est très loin de ce que
nous avons eu.
C'est très loin de l'Italie.
C'est c'est en dessous de l'Italie.
C'est pas très loin c'est surtout très
loin de l'Allemagne.
Et donc nous avons ça, nous avons aussi
des services. Nous avons des services
qui sont importants.
La dette. La dette, on fait quoi avec la
dette ?
Mais il faut faire les réformes que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure dans le
domaine des retraites, de la maladie et
des collectivités locales. Ah ben
et puis et
ah ben je n pas là pour j'ai pas les
capacités maintenant mais c'est je vous
donne des directions. Vous me
questionnez, je vous donne des
directions.
Henri quelque chose à rajouter sur la
dette ?
sur la dette.
La bamboche est finie.
Pardon ?
La bamboche est finie avec la dette.
Bon, la seule manière de de de traiter
le problème de la dette, c'est de
réduire les dépenses et d'augmenter les
recettes. Ça c'est vieux comme le monde.
Réduire les dépenses, c'est pas
supprimer de jours de travail, c'est
réduire les vraies dépenses,
c'est-à-dire le nombre de
fonctionnaires, des agences inutiles,
euh des systèmes lourds. Regardez, on a
créé des grandes régions, on a laissé
les anciennes régions en place, on a
1 feuill administratif qu'aucun pays au
monde ne connaît alors qu'on est même
pas fédéral. On est on est un pays
normalement
centralisé. Donc il y a euh des des
gaspillages euh
Bernard le disait tout à l'heure, on a
une augmentation des effectifs de
collectivité locale euh que rien ne
justifie. Euh rien. Je même pas le la
population qui ba
c'est des subordnations de vote.
Non non non, c'est un laisser aller.
C'est laisser aller. C'est un manque
d'énergie, un manque de lucidité et
cetera. Et puis sur l'Europe, moi je
suis partisan de de de la méthode un peu
un peu forte, c'estàd au fond dire bah
dans un domaine particulier, si on n'est
pas d'accord, on sort du système
européen, on le dit, on prend
on on sort pour 3 ans, on dit pendant 3
ans ou 4 ans, nous prenons nos distances
par rapport au système européen et puis
on l'assume mais euh mais on fait pas
des demi-mesures.
Et et dans le cas précis, mettre la
France à l'abri d'un système européen
absurde où on va en plus nous imposer
nouvelles contrainte, donc les
interconnexions en particulier, c'est
vraiment se mettre à l'abri de d'une
hystérique collective et d'un massacre à
venir.
La question qui est souvis de ça. La
question qui est soulevée, c'est
effectivement et ça ça peut s'étudier,
c'est de prendre nos distances sur les
contraintes que l'Europe a mis sur notre
système énergétique et auquel nous
sommes soumises et qui explique la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes.
Effectivement, ça c'est un c'est une
voie qui
ça veut pas dire sortir d'Europe. Ça
veut dire ce qu'on fait les Espagn les
Portugais, ils sont ils ont pas été
virés d'Europe. Ils ont dit "Écoutez,
nous dans les circonstances actuelles,
on préfère prendre de la distance par
rapport à ça. Et on on les a laissé
faire. Pourquoi ?
Alors, on les a laissé faire parce que
ils soi-disant leurs interconnex avec le
reste
de de l'Europe sont limités. Ce qui est
exact, il y a pas beaucoup de
d'interconnexion électrique qui passent
nécessairement par la France. s'exposer
bien sûr au même prix d'électricité
àation
et et donc cette disposition est
intervenue au moment où le prix du gaz a
explosé et donc euh le le pays de la
péninsule ibérique, l'Espagne et le
Portugal ont obtenu de l'Europe que le
gouvernement puisse subventionner
les producteurs d'électricité espagnol
et portugais euh ce qui évidemment a
conduit à avoir une électricité qui
infinait était moins chère et d'ailleurs
il y a eu des délocalisations
des Étatsmembres vers des États de la
péninsule ibérique. Ce qui veut dire que
même si là il y avait l'argument des
interconnexion,
si la France avait une volonté de faire
et le courage d'aller jusqu'à la crise,
ça pourrait se faire. Mais c'est une
question encore une fois de courage et
de volonté politique.
Alors on peut pas avoir de la volonté
dans tous les domaines parce que sinon
euh
mais dans certains secteurs ou bon un ou
deux secteurs, je pense qu'on peut se
permettre de dire pousse
sur ce sujet particulier et compte tenu
de l'histoire et compte tenu de la
spécificité française c'est vrai que
parc nucléaire français est spécifique
pas d'autres comparable en Europe. et
bien on continuera à alimenter le pays
voisin et à délivrer de l'énergie à
travers les interconnexions, mais on
reprend la maîtrise d'un système
électrique au moins pour une période
déterminée.
Question internet, les écolos sont
pointés du doigt depuis le début, soit
que pensent-il de l'affaire Alstom
Général électrique en terme
d'indépendance énergétique ?
Il y a eu une commission d'enquête qui a
été
Ouais, on sait très bien ce qu'il a né,
hein.
Stom est une catastrophe. Enfin, ça a
été voulu par pouvoir politique euh et
par des intérêts industriels enfin
financiers. On a vendu àom aux
Américains à un prix euh
dérisoire, on l'a racheté deux fois plus
cher en le lassant la propriété de la
technologie pour les deux Amériques.
Voilà.
C'est c'est c'est un scandale.
Un scandale.
C'est un scandale qui a été détaillé
dans une commission d'enquête.
Les commissions d'enquête en fait c'est
cosmétique parce que une commission
d'enquête normalement il y a des têtes
qui tombent, des têtes qui roulent, des
gens derrière les barreaux, des gens qui
remboursent, des gens qui sont virés. Là
il y a quoi ? Ça ça c'est ça c'est vous
soulevez une question très intéressante.
Merci, ça me fait plaisir.
Euh mais je peux vous le redire si vous
voulez
encore
encore ça et puis caresserez un petit
peu derrière la qui est qui est que on
peut faire les pires bêtises en disant
c'est un choix politique et on n'est pas
sanctionné.
Euh si vous êtes comme ça à la tête
d'une petite boîte, d'une moyenne boîte
et d'une grosse boîte, vous êtes viré
immédiatement voir vous êtes poursuivi.
On est poursuivi
et sur vos biens personnels.
Donc là, il y a un problème et
personnellement, je pense qu'il faudrait
étudier.
Alors, les commissions d'enquête sont
conduites à l'inefficacité lorsqu'elles
interviennent,
lorsque je dirais qu'elles mettent en
cause le courant politique qui qui est
en fonction.
Et là c'est plus compliqué.
Donc vaut mieux faire une commission
d'enquête quand on est encore au pouvoir
parce que comme ça c'est tranquille.
C'est le cas bien sûr.
Non
admettons admettons que le Front
National passe et qu'on relance une
Oui. Rassemblement national.
Jordane Marine bon eux ils passent. On
relance une commission d'enquête. On a
le droit de relancer une commission
d'enquête pour voir un petit peu qui a
fait les malins ?
Oui oui oui. Les commissions d'enquête,
c'est une décision
du bureau des assemblées mais à
l'Assemblée nationale et c'était ce que
j'avais mis dans le règlement, chaque
groupe politique a a droit à un tirage
un droit de tirage sur des commissions
d'enquête. Oui, c'est possible.
Euh on arrive à la fin de notre
interview.
Euh je vais vous poser une question. Euh
trois bouquins. Pendant qu'enri nous
donne trois bouquins, je vais regarder
les questions que notre communauté va
nous faire remonter. Donc ça va vous
laisser un peu de temps pour voter.
Henry, trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté. Autre que euh Tintin euh ou
pourquoi autre ?
Ma culture c'est Tintin. Mais j'ai j'ai
vécu dans Tintin. Donc non mais euh mais
il y a plein plein de livres qui
méritent d'être lu. Faut mais moi
j'adore les romans policiers. Donc
le dernier livre de Bruno Lemire
euh ça ça mê pas venu à l'idée tiens.
Non
mais je je c'est un tort
vraisemblablement.
Euh
moi j'aime beaucoup les polars. J'aime
Pendant que vous réfléchissez question
internet. On ne peut pas réformer
l'Union européenne, il faut 54 entités
pour changer une virgule.
Ces hommes sont incapables de penser en
dehors du cadre de l'Union européenne.
Ils sont où les Français ceux qu'on
appelait la Fiosa Francesca après la
révolution ? Ça c'était Destiny à
Bernard. Bon alors les livres encore 2
minutes le temps de chercher.
Bernard vous voulez répondre à ça là ?
Elle est où la la FYosa Francesca là ?
Non mais il faut faire avec les
réalités. on peut pas du jour au
lendemain changer ce qui s'impose. Donc
ce qui est possible, c'est domaine par
domaine de régler un certain nombre de
problèmes. Je pense que c'est à la
portée d'un gouvernement qui
l'annoncerait, en prendrait l'engagement
devant les Français, qui serait conduit
au pouvoir par les Français et qui à ce
titre pourrait faire valoir ses
intentions de réforme de se retirer de
tel ou tel domaine. À ce moment-là,
l'Europe tient compte en général du de
la volonté des peuples, des
Étatsmembres.
On va à la guerre avec les Russes là ou
pas ? Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Je pense que la situation
géopolitique mondiale est effectivement
extrêmement inquiétante, que les pays du
sud global, globalement des pays qui ne
sont pas des pays démocratiques,
sont désormais rassemblés, alliés,
cèdent dans la guerre contre contre
l'Ukraine et que en face les pays
occidentaux sont dans le doute compte
tenu des décisions euh assez brutales du
président Trump. même s'il a rappelé aux
Européens que il devait ils auraient dû
depuis longtemps mettre davantage la
main à la poche pour leur propre leur
propre défense et puis on faut quand
même pas oublier que nous venons de
vivre et nous vivons encore la plus
longue période de paix en France
sur notre territoire métropolitain mais
ça la période de paix en terme de guér
et que l'homme n'a pas changé et que par
conséquent et que par conséquent nous
devons savoir et nous devrions savoir et
nous n'aurions pas dû oublier que une
guerre peut à nouveau survenir. Je je
j'en profite d'avoir un politicien au
politique en face de moi.
Non, j'ai fini la politique.
Bon, à feu politique, j'ai l'impression
que les politiques de nos jours, la
guerre économique pour eux, comme c'est
pas une guerre pampan avec des balles
des morts, ah ben on est en paix.
On se fait saccager notre industrie, on
se fait saccager nos contrats, on se
fait écouter. Il y a des gens de l'autre
côté de l'Atlantique qui nous font des
crocheptes. Mais la pax américana, tout
va bien, tout c'est bien, ça se passe
bien. Là, on est la vraie guerre.
En réalité, on on ne mesure jamais que
tout est en train de changer autour de
nous et la guerre ne sera plus ce
qu'elle était. la guerre 14, la guerre
de 2è guerre mondiale, c'était des
affrontements différents. On voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui euh la cyberguerre,
les guerres d'influence peuvent être
presque plus dommageables.
Bernard, c'est quoi l'ordre mélien ?
Pardon ?
C'est quoi l'ordre mélien ?
Alors, je sais pas ce que c'est.
Oh, c'est un truc qui vieux comme
Mathusalem. Henry, trois livres.
Bon, j'ai du mal à dire. Moi, j'adore
les bouquins d'histoire, j'adore les
bouquins de de science-fiction et
j'adore les romans policier. Donc, j'en
lis
un auteur de science-fiction,
Lovecraft ou
Isaac ?
Ouais, Isaac. Ouais,
Isaac, c'est pas mal hein.
Ouais.
Ah ouais,
fantastique. Mais on en a eu tellement
enfin
Ray Bradburry
moins
moins. Enfin bon,
Far c'était pas mal quand même non ?
Ouais. Ou oui, c pas enfin Isaac, c'est
quand même autre chose.
Fondation.
Ouais,
extraordinaire.
Ouais, le monde des non enfin mais je il
y a une liste impressionnante. J'ai j'ai
dévoré ça pendant des années et je
retrouve d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
je je me surprends à à constater que le
monde actuel ressemble beaucoup à ce qui
figurait dans ces romansl.
C'est des remes de prospective
un peu enfin ça se voulait ça se voulait
pas dans de prospective en fait mais
mais
on retrouve la la déraison actuelle fait
queon retrouve quand même beaucoup de
résonance dans ces bouquins qui quand on
les relit effectivement ressemble à des
romans d'anticipation.
Bernard, les outils démocratiques
directs façon Suisse, c'est bien ou
c'est pas bien ? les alors la démocratie
directe
soulève la question de l'efficacité et
de l'influence
des groupes activistes. C'est-à-dire que
si on décide de faire une consultation
directe,
ce qu'on appelle la démocratie
participative, c'est un petit groupe qui
va donner des idées là sur
l'environnement, le climat, là sur la
fin de vie, manifestement, on est
obligé, enfin concrètement, on est
obligé de former ces gens-là, on va les
formater, c'est un petit groupe et
quelques-uns d'entre eux vont convaincre
le groupe ou les formateurs auront
convaincu le groupe. Donc je suis très
réservé vis-à-vis de la démocratie
participative. Néanmoins, je pense qu'il
faut recueillir la vie des Français
individuellement. Quand je présidais
l'Assemblée, j'avais essayé de mettre en
place un dispositif qui permettait à
tous les internautes, à tous les
Français euh d'émettre leur avis sur tel
ou tel projet de loi, tel ou tel
problème et le rapporteur du texte
aurait eu connaissance de de tout cela
et aurait pu en faire la synthèse et en
tenir ou ne pas en tenir compte selon sa
ses choix et la volonté du parlement.
Question internet qui est dure Bernard,
je vais quand même vous la poser.
C'est une question un peu provoc
provocatrice.
Monsieur Bernard, à quoi il est
pensez-vous que les Nicolas Kipet vont
bien vouloir continuer à financer les
boomers comme vous ? Comment allez-vous
survivre à vos vieux jours ? Mais non,
c'est c'est évidemment quelque chose qui
va se concrétiser. On n'a pas prévu le
financement du vieillissement de la
population.
les retraites et les soins aux personnes
âgées dont les prix explosent et par
conséquent
la la réalité va s'imposer. Les
couvertures vont diminuer probablement
le panier de soin va se restreindre et
les retraites baisseront. C'est
malheureusement l'arithmétique qui va
s'imposer et et ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure, le refus des réalité et
le problème auquel nous sommes
confrontés, toute génération confondu,
les boomers comme les autres hein.
Question internet encore pour Bernard.
Bernard, vous avez vraiment énervé notre
communauté aujourd'hui. Est-ce que
Bernard dit qu'on ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi et se retirer de l'Union
européenne parce que il a peur de ce qui
arriverait ? Point d'interrogation.
Est-ce qu'il ne se sent pas Est-ce qu'il
ne sent pas que le peuple français se
rapproche du seuil auquel il a plus peur
de ne pas pouvoir nourrir ses enfants
que d'avoir peur de lendemain inconnu ?
Mais et évidemment que je suis
parfaitement lucide euh vis-à-vis du
toboggan sur lequel notre pays hélas est
engagé, qui est un un toboggan qui va et
qui a déjà euh appauvri notre pays par
rapport aux citoyens des autres des
autres nations. J'ai évoqué la question
des des différentes générations ce ce
mais on ne peut encore une fois c'est
pas parce que on on va dans une
situation extrêmement dangereuse
pour les politiques ou pour nous
non pour le pays et pour les citoyens il
y a que ça qui est important
il faut mesurer les retombées de ce que
l'on engage. Prenons le cas de la
politique agricole, la politique
agricole, si on rond avec l'Europe, ben
il y a plus d'agriculture française.
C'est fini. Même si l'Europe fait
beaucoup de mal à nos agriculteurs,
malgré tout, elle contribue à leur à
leur donne.
On donne combien à l'Union européenne ?
Je peux pas vous donner le chiffre, je
ne je n'ai pas présent. Je n'ai pas
présent à l'esprit.
C'est c'est en milliards.
Ah bien sûr, évidemment. Et bah et si on
arrête de donner à l'Union européenne et
qu'on file directement à nos
agriculteurs ?
Oui. Non mais encore une fois, on est
tenu, on est tenu par des traités. C'est
facile de dire il y a qu'à faire ceci,
il y a qu'à faire cela. Enfin, il y a
quand même dans toute société, il y a
des règles du jeu, hein. Bon, donc il
faut il faut rester rester raisonnable,
même s'il faut être audacieux, s'il faut
avoir du courage, s'il faut reconnaître
les bêtises, il faut quand même rester
réaliste.
Question pour Henri.
Vous avez lu d'une ou vous avez vu d'une
d'une
l'épice les gros verts ? Non. C'est
dommage. Bon, la question c'était
l'avenir de l'énergie suivra-t-il le
même que l'épice dans d'une Faut
regarder d'une, il faut lire d'une
pardon. Non.
Ah bah là, il faut lire d'une là. Bah
si, là, c'est obligatoire.
Non, mais au moins j'apprends quelque
chose ce soir. Enfin, je
Ah bah obligatoire. Deuxème épisode
encore meilleur
Bernard trois livres.
Moi, je me suis mis à lire tardivement
parce que j'ai j'ai été accaparé par ma
vie professionnelle.
parce que vous aviez des retards.
Oui, j'ai pas lu quand j'étais jeune,
quand j'ai plus j'étais plus intéressé
par les maths, la physique, la médecine
que par les bouquins et puis j'avais pas
le temps. Donc j'ai pas lu. Je me suis
mis assez tardivement à lire quand j'en
ai eu le temps. Et donc j'ai quelques
livres euh que j'ai commencé par lire
qui étaient des livres connus. Et
je peux vous bloquer tout de suite.
Oui.
Comment il s'appelle votre dernier
bouquin ?
Alors celui que je suis en train de lire
en ce moment.
Non, le vôtre à vous. Alors, le dernier
c'était
euh euh une affaire d'État, la tentative
de saordage du nucléaire français.
Quelles éditions ?
Euh Hugo,
quel tarif ?
Pour moins de 20 moins de 20 €.
Vous touchez combien là-dessus ? Euh,
zéro. J'ai touché zéro. Mais pourquoi
toucher combien en retraite de
l'Assemblée nationale ?
Euh Ah oui, c'est une retraite de
l'Assemblée nationale qui s'établit
autour de 4000 €.
Nette, brut ?
Net. Vous êtes pour pour ou contre le
fait qu'on va taxer un peu plus les
pensions de retraite ?
Ah ben je pense que de toute façon si
les revenus
euh sont taxé bah les tensions retraite
le seront y compris avec l'avantage des
10 % pour frais professionnels.
Et est-ce qu'il faut taxer l'épargne des
Français ou est-ce qu'il faut l'inciter
à être regoûté vers la défense ?
Écoutez, ça c'est technique, je peux pas
répondre à cette question. Oui,
moi je aussi la toute idée de taxation
de l'épargne parce que l'épargne c'est
ce qui reste après qu'on a déjà été
ponctionné par l'impôt à un niveau
incomparablement plus élevé que le reste
du monde.
Pourquoi l'orienter vers la défense
plutôt que vers autre chose ? Enfin, ça
n'a pas de sens. Ça n'a pas de raison.
Le panne des français n'a pas être
orienté. Laissons aux français au moins
la liberté de savoir ce qu'il font de
leur épargne.
En général, il le il le gère mieux que
l'État. l'impression
justement
question une dernière c'est vous êtes
pour le partage de l'arme nucléaire ou
pas ?
Non,
on peut pas partager parce qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui appuie sur le bouton
et donc ça c'est une décision
nationale.
Les trois livres Bernard. Alors, les
trois livres, celui que je suis en train
de lire en ce moment et qui me
passionne, c'est le bouquin d'un d'un
sociologue que j'aime bien qui s'appelle
Gérard Bronner et qui s'appelle
à l'assaut du réel, c'est-à-dire qui
développe ce que je vous ai dit, le fait
que les Français et les générations qui
se succèdent depuis plusieurs décennies
refusent de voir le réel, les problèmes
tels qu'ils sont, l'avenir tel qu'il
est, les difficultés et puis dans les
bouquins que j'ai lu parce que je
voulais lire des livres connus.
J'entendais toujours des gens cultivés
en parler. Donc ça me tracassait de ne
pas les avoir lu. Ceux qui m'ont plus
marqué, c'est l'étranger de Camu et puis
évidemment le bouquin d'Orwell 1984.
Il y a un commentaire. Bernard, un
traité, ça se dénonce quand c'est
inique.
Ben, c'est surtout qu'avant que avant de
dénoncer un traité, on peut aussi, ce
que la France ne fait pas euh attaquer
les décisions de la Commission
européenne quand elle ne respecte pas
les traités. Or, la France qui se veut
consensuelle, qui ne veut pas rentrer en
en crise avec la commission, ne le fait
pas. Souvenons-nous de De Gaulle qui lui
n'avait pas hésité à pratiquer la
politique de la chaise vide.
Henry, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose qui restera impérissable.
Oh, il y a beaucoup de sujets. Enfin,
euh
bon, ce que ce que j'ai essayé de
communiquer aux jeunes parce que j'ai
essayé de former, j'avais créé une une
école d'apprentissage qui était la
référence en la matière. Très bien. Bon,
donc enfin, faites-vous confiance à
vous-même. Prenez votre destin en main.
N'attendez pas toujours qu'on qu'on vous
prenne par la main. Deuxièmement,
tout le monde a dans sa vie des
opportunités. Sachez les les saisir.
C'est-à-dire
quand les opportunités se présentent,
faut pas hésiter, faut avoir l'audace
de en tout cas en toute lucidité de
saisir.
Et puis trois, au lieu de regarder
toujours vers le haut. pour voir si vous
méritez
euh la je dirais la reconnaissance de
vos chefs. Regardez autour de vous et
demandez-vous si vous méritez le respect
de vos collaborateurs parce que c'est
beaucoup plus fort et que ceux qui vous
portent vous porteront beaucoup plus
durablement et beaucoup plus haut que
ceux qui vous tirent.
Avant de demander la même question à
Bernard, je déd message personnel je
dédie cette émission à Olivier Marlex et
Loï Lefloc Prent
Bernard, un conseil pour les jeunes
génération, une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose d'impérissable.
Croyez en vous.
Ayez une espérance parce que vous avez
la chance d'être français, de vivre dans
un pays qui est un des plus beaux du
monde avec des atouts incroyables et
réveillez le pays. C'est votre
génération qui peut le le réveiller et
c'est vous-même qui bénéficierez de ce
réveil.
Bernard Henri, merci.
Merci.
[Musique]